Elon Musk says it may be time to bring
back Alex Jones after Tucker Carlson
dropped his interview with Alex Jones
about a half an hour long the quartering
tweeted that it's time to bring him back
and Elon Musk said yeah let's run a poll
and then someone else tweeted here's why
Alex Jones was banned in the first place
and Elon Musk says that doesn't sound
like I'm paraphrasing but that's not a
legitimate reason for a ban on someone
so it may be that we are winning the
censor well we are literally winning
against the censorship industrial
complex but we're also winning against
the woke industrial complex because now
we got this big firm saying they're
going to pull $100 million out of
universities over these presidents
defending far-left calls for uh so so I
want to be very careful on this one Al
Le stonic asked these presidents if
calling for the genocide of Jews broke
their rules and they all said well I
guess it depends on the context this is
resulting in a massive backlash which is
particularly interesting so we'll talk
about that plus we got to talk about V
Grandma Swami he said a whole bunch of
things on stage last night at the GP
debate he said January 6 looks like an
inside job he's wrong January 6 is
definitively an inside job because
there's videos of police officers
opening the door Fanning people in
taking selfies with them and giving them
guided tours so if that's not an inside
job I don't know what is but he also
said that great replacement theory is
not a conspiracy theory it's Democrat
policy and of course now van Jones has
said he's shaking hearing this man who's
going to outlive Trump by 50 years and
this is the ride of like Nazi fascist
whatever okay well how about I play a
clip of Van Jones saying that he and and
the woke left are asking white people to
give up on being a majority and accept
becoming a minority quite literally
echoing claims made by by those who are
discussing a great replacement so we'll
talk about that before we do head over
to cast brew.com if you'd like to buy
the best cup of coffee you've ever had
you can pick up your rise with Roberto
Jr limited edition once it's gone it's
gone forever but everybody's favorite
seems to be Appalachia nights and in
second place rise with Roberto Jr now
for a while rise with Roberto Jr was
number one that's our dark roast our
light roast and we also have stand your
grounds and medium roast it's whole bean
it's ground your choice as well as K
Cups this is part of our plan to open a
physical location we've got one uh
coming up in Martinsburg West Virginia
we're probably going to open the private
skate shop and Club first because that's
super easy to do and that is currently
underway as well but when you go to
casper.com and you buy our coffee you're
supporting that mission but don't forget
to also go to
timcast.net
uh the latest documentary and of course
we're going to have the uncensored
members only show coming up tonight
where you as members can actually call
in and talk to us and our guests so it
should be a lot of fun smash that that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us tonight to talk about this and
everything else is rep Eli crane thanks
for having me guys oh sounds like your
mic's not on did we get it nope oh we
had I think we had that issue we were
having a similar issue microphone that's
weird I'll figure that out here what's
going on I think it's so the the other
day we had a headphone problem I'm
wondering if whatever is joint like
bringing these cables together is
busted is it I mean it was working like
literally 3 minutes ago yeah here in the
meantime wait I heard something
Che come sit over here in the meantime
while we work on it you you you'll be
honorary
Ian
helloe do we know what happened uh not
yet trying to figure it out all right
well uh there you go who are you what do
you do uh Eli crane man I'm currently a
congressman from Arizona uh former
former small business
owner um uh Navy veteran as well so Dad
husband all of that right on WE we've
got some interesting stuff coming out of
Congress I guess Jamal Bowman got got
censured yep yeah we'll talk about that
and it's just kind of funny uh Kevin
McCarthy resigned he's gone I mean was
that a big deal for you guys no one
seemed to care he just kind of
disappeared yeah I think it was kind of
surprising uh I don't think too many
people saw that coming um I was one of
the uh eight who voted him out right on
so yeah who um oh that was it right
there that's awesome I think obviously
just heard a noise and if you want we
can just talk into it you can't we can
just do this nothing hey you can just do
this if you want search because this
works I can hear uh I think people can
hear me we can just swivel that
microphone I I mean it's making noises
but I think the cable broke think the C
might be don't know WRA what's going on
probably just need to get a new cable
yeah probably oh I know I know what
happens people keep spinning the arm
around and then it ripped the cable out
yeah like tore the threads on the inside
of the doesn't have a camera either I'll
move your drinks Ian if you want me to
swap with you brother yeah once we get
everything set up we can re refabricate
the uh anyway philon is here hanging out
hi everybody my name is Phil I'm the
lead singer of all the remains the heavy
metal band I'm uh failed musician uh
anti-communist and a
counterrevolutionary and Ian is bouncing
around the table what up I'm sitting in
Dicky Barrett's chair you guys see that
show that was awesome there were a lot
of people up sat in that chair Milo Milo
sat milonopoulos sat here uh this is
like a this is a golden CH I like the
having the musical stuff in the
background I'll only be here for a
little while little while these
headphones are a little jacked too I
think it they slide out of the out of
the this thing they lock into place well
it is what it is when it's in it's in
these things happen and then uh Serge is
pressing the buttons yeah trying to
figure this all out here Serge is
running dude Serge is like a hurricane
he's spinning around the room it's
showing me that it's feeding but there's
just nothing coming through so looks at
the cable I don't know cool can you we
had a problem with that yesterday too
awesome well say love Visa how about we
just jump into the news then you want to
switch now yeah let's do it all right
there we go all right and while they're
doing that here's the story from the
post millennial Elon Musk considers
bringing Alex Jones back to X will run a
poll to decide so here's what happens we
uh we have Tucker Carlson drop his
interview with Alex Jones the quartering
tweets think about how much letting Alex
Jones back on X would make the machine
rage Elon Musk it's time Elon responds
will consider in general since this
platform aspires to be the global Town
Square permanent banss should be
extremely rare also if he does say
something false on this platform then
Community notes will correct him whereas
that would not be the case elsewhere and
then he says let's hold a poll so this
could be it I think uh I I think with
this boycott the attack against Elon
Musk and X which is clearly nonsensical
uh Elon earlier was tweeting at Disney
because Instagram and met uh Instagram
and Facebook meta companies were sued by
the New Mexico AG for advancing allowing
and facilitating child abuse and all
that entails trafficking Etc and
materials and so Elon Musk is saying why
why are they still advertising on these
on this platform how come all these
advertisers are on Facebook with no
problem about something we've all known
about now for how it's been like a year
since the initial reports came out that
they were doing this and no action's
been taken and they're boycotting X I
think actions like that result in Elon
being like all right screw it Alex Jones
is back I I think that Alex Jones coming
back is probably baked into the kick now
I I don't know that I don't know that I
agree that the the treatment of musk
currently by the government and by the
other media establishment um is is the
defining factor I think that the
conversation that that um Tucker Carlson
had with with uh with with Jones I
listened to about half of it on the way
on the way here today um and I think
that there's a lot of compelling uh
there's a lot of compelling stuff in the
conversation that would that would I
think would make musk uh kind of sit up
and be like oh I I misunderstood because
if I understand correctly musk's
position was Alex Jones did do this and
that's why he was booted off and
apparently um that is not the case so I
I don't I don't know I think Elon musk's
position was is publicly whoa Alex Jones
said a bunch of bad things so you know
there's there's a line but in reality it
was guys there's only so much I can do
right we he was trying to avoid having
every Advertiser just jump off the
platform but if that's happening already
seems like elon's like all right screw
it whatever well I think I mean he
probably kind of I mean maybe there is a
little more to your initial comment than
I than I initially said because he's
probably he probably is thinking well
you know they're banning they're they're
affecting my advertising base anyways
right like I've done the things that
that you're supposed to do to get along
with them but because I own X and don't
want to you know just allow the FBI to
have an office in my building um because
of that then they're still going to go
and try and attack me and and try and
ruin the business I think that uh I
think that he that that probably does
have an a significant impact on his his
take fully agree that's exactly what I
think is happening they and I would even
consider that the advertisers aren't
even boycotting X they're boycotting
Elon they're it's a personal it seems
person I think it's
governmental oh I think yeah like I said
I like that's why I said uh mentioned an
FBI desk in Twitter because that's
essentially what they had before I
forget what his name was the guy that
was the FBI lawyer that worked at
Twitter he was the Twitter's top lawyer
but in the same way that you don't leave
the Intel establishment like if you get
out of you know you stop working at CIA
and you go working go to a uh a tech
company you're still working for CIA at
a tech company you have the connections
you're still making you still have the
you know you still can talk to the
people that you used to work with and
you know for a fact the higher ups the
bureau Chiefs and Stu or the higher-ups
at at CIA are calling you up and saying
hey can you get me this or can you do
this if they want something from the
tech companies You could argue that tech
companies big tech companies are we can
be weaponized I mean just like Boeing
can be weaponized they're 100% already
part of the military industrial compx
exactly but they also make commuter Jets
like they'll make commercial airliners
but then they were also machines were
ized for war and social media I think
can also be very very easily so is there
are they right do you what do you think
well I I want to ask you did have you
worked on any of the weaponization stuff
while they're they're tracking what was
going on with collusion no I haven't I'm
on homeland security small business and
Veterans Affairs and I think it's great
I'd love to see Alex back on uh back on
X yeah oh he's back on homand security
you have to have a a clearance for that
and stuff clearance for what for
Homeland Security oh yeah yeah every
member of Congress get clearance okay I
didn't know that yeah what is it no uh
uh what level of clearance are we are we
allowed to know um I mean I don't think
there's too much that you're not allowed
to see as a member of Congress no I mean
like does the public know the degree of
clearance that members of Congress get
is it publicly known like if you're in
Congress you get top secret or something
yeah yeah I I mean yeah you you you get
top secret oh okay well then yeah I want
to know what's going on with uh uh I I
don't think it's a coincidence that
meta's meta's apps are now why why wi
reporting about the facilitation of
child abuse not a single Advertiser
cares the same thing happened with with
the whole January 6 thing everybody all
of the evidence shows that the people
that did talk about you know going to
the protest and possibly rioting or
whatever they were all making the coners
they were all having conversations on
Facebook and yet the government blamed
parlor and went after parlor
infrastructure and basically you know
torpedoed
parlor saying that people were
organizing for the protests and stuff on
parlor when reality they were doing it
on Facebook then it makes me think that
there is massive government
infrastructure in Facebook and they're
happy to keep it open business because
it's like a Honeypot absolutely the the
tech companies whether we realized it or
not the the big social media companies
that we decided you know as a society we
are just going to give all of our
information to
they are the the monitoring apparatus
for the federal government because the
federal government just needs a subpoena
like we we we they don't have to like it
doesn't have to be this big brother
nefarious where they're putting speakers
and stuff or putting microphones in your
car and stuff cuz they're already there
in fact we we bought all the speakers
and and stuff to put into our own you
know our own homes so they don't have to
do anything except go to a court and say
uh you know we need a we need you know
we need to subpoena the records we need
to subpoena the communications for this
person for these dates all they have to
do is know where to look the government
will go to the the court the court is
there are I would be willing to bet
anything there is not a court in America
that will turn the federal government
down if they say we need to get we need
to subpoena this information from Google
I wonder if there was a if there was an
option for us to scramble all data on
all social networks so that no one has
access to it if that would actually be
good for the American military
industrial complex defense organiz like
they'd be like yeah it's better that no
one has it cuz right now yeah the FBI
might have access to it but sort of this
Chinese CCP they can they can hack it
and take it too and I I wonder if what
if it what they would do if they could
do that because I'm thinking about
Quantum encryption and and post
encryption and stuff like that I want to
say that there was already some kind of
legislation about encryption that the
government doesn't want the population
or the private sector to have encryption
technology they want to we they want to
consider it a weapon and say that the
that you know uh companies can't have
encryption that was one of the I heard I
don't have any detail about it I this is
just something that I heard in passing
and I haven't done any kind of studying
up on it but it doesn't surprise me
because the government hates the idea of
not being able to access information
there's like I just did a conversation
with Kevin Kane who does Quantum
encryption or postquantum encryption I
think it's what it's called and they're
they're trying to figure out get ahead
of the game because once they figure out
how to crack encryption with quantum
computers then they need to put some
kind of new encryption in place and and
it's like is it even ethical to talk
about this out loud cuz even if we're
just spitballing ideas like they're
listening you know I mean they like the
CC whoever the the boogy man is at the
day I'm confident the government has
people working for them that are way
smarter than me that have thought of
things that I'm not going to think of
yeah a lot of SE I'm I'm not worried
about if I like I'm not worried about
giving the government ideas a lot of the
the federal government is getting ahead
of the curve but it's kind of that thing
like until you know how it can be broken
you don't know what to make to fix it to
to prevent it from being broken so you
got to break it before you can improve
it and then that could be like bank
records get released everybody's phone
calls texts uh all that signal all your
encryption stuff is like you know a
quantum computer can can take Vector
attacks like rather than trying to be
like ABC D ABC ABC you don't even need
to have quantum computer because like I
said you just got the courts the courts
just say give it to them and then what
if you don't give it to them no no what
I'm saying is that is like Google
they'll the court will go to Google and
say Google give it to them give it the
information if if if if there's back
door access through these big companies
I think that I don't think that there
needs to be backdoor access I think just
the the federal government can just go
to the court say we need this
information and you're saying the
corporations will hand it over yeah
right right Verizon all these big big
companies I think they've been know I
think there's been reports that they
just do the only company that I that I'm
aware of that gave them the government
the middle finger was Apple when they
wanted to get into that guy's iPhone CU
he committed a terrorist attack and they
wanted to open and then I think the FED
said you know what never mind we don't
need it we got it anyway I apparent I
mean that that might have been how it
was resolved I don't remember but I do
remember that Apple was like no we're
not we're not because they wanted to
build a back door or something like that
and they're like look if we if we show
you a back door or build a back door
into this that it it's for all of them
then yeah and actually in terms of what
Apple's trying to build the best
marketing for the fact that they have it
is that they publicly say no to the FBI
and then they're like n we're not giving
it to you because we built a thing and
that's good for everyone else too so buy
our products I'm thinking like if I keep
thinking decentralized social media so
that the companies don't have access to
your messages they're all encrypted
peer-to-peer but now I'm like well if
those truly are weapons of war social
media
machines and things like that social
media algorithms we can't de or could we
decentralize Boe that wouldn't make a
lot of sense because then it becomes a
security risk how you build the plane
when the parts aren't in the same
building you'd have to get them to ship
them to their location and if one of
those factories goes down and can't get
the bolts over to the main Factory to
put the aircraft together the entire
thing shuts down so it's almost like a
risk not to have it centralized that's
that's that's how stuff goes as it is
especially like in actually we talked
about this the other night at the
military um if you're building a complex
piece of equipment for the military they
try to spread out the actual parts
manufacturing into as many congressional
districts as possible so that way if you
want to get rid of a a program you're
getting rid of a bunch of jobs that
Congress people are like ah you're not
taking these jobs from my district yeah
I was talking to Congressman Gates about
that and he was telling me that uh some
of the some of the smartest folks that's
how they'll do it with some of these
fighter jets and whatnot they'll make
sure that you know a piece is made in
every single state that way if you know
you'll have every all the representation
fighting to keep that same fighter um
online and it's smart you know but it I
don't know man it's definitely not in
it's definitely not in the best interest
of the American people right it's an
addiction yeah it's it's it's a
programmed addiction by these uh uh
government actors making these deals
whoever it may be legislators or
otherwise where they're they're trying
to make sure we can never shut down a
government program that's the biggest
problem we have with government is the
inability for it to fail so when bad
things happen when corrupt things happen
when failure happens the machine keeps
going sucking in more and more money
becoming more and more corrupt and then
eventually imploding that's exactly the
the argument that Libertarians make
about private sector versus public
sector anything in the government
there's no way for it to be punished by
failing other than people voting people
out and to be honest with you the
failure has to be on such a catastrophic
level to get people to say this guy
needs to go it has to be really bad for
a lot of people um whereas in the
private sector if you're if you're if
you're not making money two quarters in
a row the higher ups are looking to
replace everybody you know if you're if
you if you're if you go from being in
the black you know to in the red they're
like yo why look at what's going on with
uh um at Disney you know there there's
they're people talking about they're
writing letters to their investors
saying yo we know that things have been
messed up stick with us we're going to
make changes and stuff you know you've
covered the those I I want to jump to
this story because we've got someone who
actually can provide some uh some good
answers here and help us understand we
got this from The New York Times house
censures Jamal Bowman for false fire
alarm lawmakers voted to formally rebuke
Mr Bowman for setting off a false fire
alarm in the house office building the
latest partisan use of a once rare
congressional action forly reserved for
grave offenses uh rep crane what is
censure what does that mean yeah it's
just basically like a slap on the wrist
I mean it really it's it's really not
not anything substantive I mean he's
going to yeah he's going to have
commercials run up you know by his
opponents that he was censured but it
really doesn't do much and it just does
do anything not not really no it's offic
it's it's offici it's the official way
for Congress to disapprove of you yeah
he he had he had to go down to it
happened today I was you know there on
the house floor and he basically had to
go down to the well which is like right
in front of where the speaker chair is
and you know they they they read his
censure and he had to stand there
publicly and all the Democrats like
crowded around him didn't they all vote
in support of him or something yeah yeah
the Democrats voted in support of him
but he did pull obviously he pulled he
pulled the fire alarm pulled the fire
alarm and uh I I remember the day it
happened and I thought it was a joke
when people were telling me that he
pulled the pulled the fire alarm and it
was kind of ironic and funny that you
know he was a principal um he was acting
like he did he he thought it was like
going to let him out of the door or
something he ja and I think he should be
expelled from Congress I think cure is
too light let let me ask you why was why
was uh Santos expelled for being too
awesome but seriously though like like
what what was the actual offense he
committed in Congress that that
warranted expulsion yeah I I know he had
a bunch of indictments I didn't vote to
expel him I I voted to keep him um but I
know that I know that the New York
delegation was really pushing hard for
him to go and this was just my theory it
just my thought I
think I I think that a lot of the New
York constituents and donors that got
burnt by Santos were putting a lot of
pressure on those guys to get rid of
George now if you ever met George in
person like the guys he's hilarious um
I'm not going to sit here and defend
George's like Persona what he did what
did he do I I don't know well they they
said he used a bunch of campaign funds
to you know buy you know he broke a lot
of campaign Finance laws like he used
campaign funds to like get BOTOX and get
like just a bunch of consumer goods and
services that you're not allowed not
allowed to do stuff like that um using
people's credit cards um that that were
donors to like buy stuff like that so I
he had a bunch of indictments yeah um
but yeah I mean serious but the my my
concern with it is though if that
becomes the standard right you're
indicted and then we can kick you out we
can kick you out of Congress because of
a report the Ethics Committee did in my
opinion that opens up uh you know a
pretty big door especially when we're
watching you know former president Trump
they're trying to do the same thing to
him they're trying to destroy him with
lawfare and indictments and so I don't
like the predent it's why many of us
tried to save George and we saved him
more we we saved him um in the past but
it he's not convicted of anything no
could he be that's wild oh yeah he can
be and some of my colleagues I've talked
to some of my colleagues who are lawyers
and prosecutors who who do believe he
will be but I don't know man that's not
my area I don't know that I don't know
what else that means I mean Trump will
be convicted I don't see a scenario in
which Trump is acquitted by by these
liberal juries I don't either but I
would think you would wait until a
conviction before you expel which yeah
which is why I think many of us were
trying to save him you know but we know
Jamal Bowman intentionally pulled the
fire alarm we know he lied about it he's
on camera pulling the warning signs off
the door or he flicks one onto the floor
and then pulls the alarm and runs away
he didn't try to open the door he's he
lied and I'm I'm surprised that you can
have a a member of Congress commit a
crime on camera caught doing it to
subvert the political process and this
is it he slap on the wrist yeah if it
was like at 4 in the morning and he was
pranking people that would be different
than if he was doing it during a still a
crime yeah but now he was doing it
during a congressional proceeding to try
and delay the proceeding like that
well I don't know his intent I assume
it's to delay the proceeding but did it
delay a proceeding I don't know that it
delayed the proceeding and I I heard
that's what his intent was I don't know
exactly what his intent was but yeah
that's what he did he said it was
because he he was late and he needed to
get out the door or something yeah and
so he took the sign off the door that
said emergency exit well was funny cuz a
bunch a couple of my colleagues Andy
bigs is in that same building
Congressman bigs and uh he went he went
to that exit uh along with some other
guy saw that there were they had already
coed it off and so they just went around
to a different in you know a different
exit um so it doesn't make a lot of
sense that that he did what he did but I
don't honestly I don't know why that
surprises you Tim I mean it's you know I
mean it's Congress
man you know Menendez has gold bars I
mean that's the it's like yeah that's
crazy the place is ripe with I was I was
uh stuff I was hanging out at the uh
local Poker Room last week and someone
asked some guy said I'll make a bet with
all the older guy just out of the blue
goes I'll make a $20 bet with all of you
that he goes right now the approval
rating of Congress is
177% but all the 80% of Congress will be
reelected in 2024 yeah and and uh uh
well I explain them I was like well yeah
it's because we like our rep we hate all
yours so Congress is going to have a low
approval rating yeah but it but it is
funny considering nobody likes Congress
yeah just just approve writing in the
gutter everybody views it as corrupt I
don't like it either how many I I I
think I was I was talking to uh Matt
Gates and he said there's like how what
number did he give 10 or 12 good good
members of Congress or something like
that yeah it's something like that man
it's pretty it's pretty small maybe more
it's pretty small like how do you how do
you be considered good in Congress cuz
like obstructing kind of is your job but
if if you obstruct too much
then are you considered a bad guy yeah
Thomas Massie kind of gets that from I'm
definit I definitely fall under that um
I would say that that label if you will
but you're right it is tough because you
you don't want to obstruct to the point
where you can't get anything done but at
the same time when I mean take pick a
topic whether you're talking about the
Border whether you're talking about the
national debt 33 trillion plus in debt
$2 trillion annual deficit and what we
do uh under uh Republican control in
this Congress we made a deal with Joe
Biden an additional $4 trillion to the
national debt and so it's like it
doesn't really matter what topic you
pick I I I think that we're failing and
you know so if you're
obstructing that that type of failure in
in in my opinion you know I think we're
in Idiocracy right you 100% the movie
yeah they're watering the crops with
Mountain deww uh with with with the uh
Gatorade glyos to be honest is this
Gatorade yeah that that was was it Luke
Wilson it's what it's what plans plants
crave and uh he's basically salting the
Earth but I feel like we're actually in
that and the reason why is I I look at
Jamal Bowman and I'm like what a
scumbag and this is why everything's
broken this is why everybody hates
Congress this is why nothing's getting
fixed this is why we're having all these
problems well I should say it is a
component of I think we have cultural
issues yeah but I I look at so so many
of these members of Congress and it's
it's crazy to me that Jamal Jamal Bowman
pulled the fire alarm Jamie Rasin
falsely accused me of advocating for
January 6 in in the in the j6 hearings
yeah because I reported on a Fox news
story that Donald Trump called for
protests on January 6 so before January
6 happens I'm reading a news story from
Fox News where I'm like wow Trump's
calling for a protest that's GNA get
crazy like things get crazy down there
if Trump calls for this yeah he runs
clips of me out of context included in a
montage of people screaming kick the
door and things like this right that
that that guy's 20 minutes from here
rasing people who work at this company
are he represents them right I these
people I just look at them all they are
it it it is the dregs of humanity yeah
scum lying cheating stealing without a
care for anybody else they don't want to
make anyone's life better they want to
make their own lives better they want to
watch you you you know you know what
they are they are the people stealing
the Fine China from the Titanic knowing
the iceberg hit but they're going to get
to they're going to run to the the
emergency rafts before anybody finds out
the emergency boats yeah I often use
that same analogy I mean there's a lot
of problems with Congress but I think it
is important that we always remember
that like Andrew Breitbart said a long
time ago he said that politics is always
Downstream of culture yep so you never
even you don't see things get to the
halls of Congress until they've been
permeating in culture for a decade you
know 5 years at a minimum speeding up
though oh it is it is but and that's
that's how I feel a lot of time because
you know you'll sit there and you'll
just watch you know good Amendment or
this good bill go down and you're like
what the hell is going on here and I
think to your point Tim it is there
there is a certain level of that like
hey this type this this thing is going
down I'm going to get mine on the way
off right yep I I 100% believe that
there are Folks up there that that's
their mentality I think it's most of
them I got the vibe that it's there's
there's too many people for the
representatives to represent like how
many people are in your in your uh so
most yeah most reps rep about 750,000
people and it's like I mean I represent
myself I can't really even represent Tim
properly if I tried because I don't I'm
not Tim so like the idea that back in
the day the least worst thing we could
do is send some brilliant guy to go
represent the 7,000 of us and hopefully
he's going to know what we're what we
all kind of need and want in our
community but now we didn't it's it's so
un unrepresentative of the humans
because there's such a diverse desire
and belief within systems like I've had
this idea like what if we just everyone
gets the has gets like the power of the
House of Representatives now we all can
work from home we can all can write
legislation and pass it onto a system
where we can all read it and put
amendments and after 30 days we can all
vote on it to pass it into the Senate
but we'd still vote for you guys that if
the power goes out you go to the place
to do it for us until the power comes
back on then we all get back to work I
think it's a bad idea and I don't think
it makes sense what do you think about
dii you know I like
honestly I I like that we have a
constitutional republic what I don't
like is like you you guys hear about the
fourth branch of government all the time
the administrative State the bureaucracy
right if you think about it there's a
bunch of unelected bureaucrats that are
in DC fulltime they look at a guy like
me who comes in there and tries to you
know shake things up a little bit and
they're just like we can just wait this
guy out you know he has he has to get
reelected every two years and by the
time he gets the documents that we're
stonewalling him on right you know it's
it's so far it's so far into the future
that people are like oh move on that's
in that's in the past and so you know I
do like the fact that we have a
constitutional republic um you know but
there you know our system has problems
like everybody else and I think right
now the administrative state is one of
our biggest problems I I think one of
the biggest mistakes we made was the
17th Amendment so I think we should
repeal that that is the uh senators by
popular vote I think that Senators
should have always been chosen by the
state legislators to represent the state
to the federal government so the the the
Kathy hoel when um Santos was actually
on the day he was he was uh removed or
whatever they voted for it Kathy oel
said that she was going to replace uh
what's his name and she obviously
doesn't have the power to do it and it's
be part of the reason why she assumed
that she did is because she doesn't have
a fundamental deep understanding of our
governmental structure she is the
executive of the state of New York
that's why and what the error that she
made is she was was thinking that she
should be sending the per selecting to
represent the the represent the people
for congress but she would select the
senator because the senator is supposed
to represent the state she would so
there's because she
misunderstands how the structure of
government works that's why she made
that that's why she said oh I'll select
for the the house the people obviously
have to select who's going to represent
them in the Congress and she would s oh
we just we just lost Phil Serge is doing
some deep deep Tren right
now so uh I'll just I'll just pick it up
from there uh the the general idea with
the 17th Amendment uh uh was that it was
there was corruption that uh state
legislatur were just picking their
buddies we can't have that that's a
mistake because now nobody cares and
knows who their state senators are and
who their state reps are and that's
substantially more important for
everything because if this country was
unified culturally to a certain degree
where everybody was paying attention to
their state reps and legislatures you
could get a Convention of States you
could actually have the states just be
like not we're changing things we don't
it's we're done with Congress we're done
with the Senate you're not getting
anything done and then there's other
ways to do it too amending the
Constitution through Congress and uh uh
through the Senate but we don't have any
of that right now and uh uh I think
think I think you need it so I I look at
this idea that you're talking about Ian
and it's a huge mistake and it's for
exactly what you were saying you it
could take you years to get the
documents you need and you're fighting
reelection every two years and if you
can maintain that you can get these
documents you Ian sitting in your room
waiting for a bill and thinking you want
to pass it bro we are going to get
people who are going to who are going to
think the polar bears are dying and so
they're going to vote to build a polar
bear Sanctuary it's it's like The
Simpsons when they built the bear Patrol
you guys remember bear Patrol one bear
wanders into Springfield one time and so
they're like okay everyone's panicking
they all voted for a referendum for the
bear Patrol and so then Homer looks at
his paycheck a week later and he sees a
bear tax and they've got like planes
flying around that's the problem with
people who I think that's why we have a
constitutional republic with
Representatives we we select the person
we think is the best for the job to do
the job like any other job and then we
trust they do the job well and if they
don't we fire them it could be that the
representatives maintain their Authority
and ability to like request documents
but that we just as Citizens gain an
ability to also produce legislation that
we can vote on together cuz like I feel
kind of helpless a lot of times looking
at Congress and being like I have no all
I can do is convince people to go
convince someone to do something Have
you ever actually like written your
Congress person um no I would make
videos to and be like call them now call
call them at 2 o'cl everyone coordinate
make a phone and and just overload them
with phone calls I'll do that kind of
thing with the internet video but I
never actually did it myself
um because I think I mean the the you're
never GNA I don't think anyone's ever
going to feel like the direct power of
being able to say or very few people are
going to be a to say hey I want this to
happen and then it happens right like
that's not like even the president
doesn't doesn't have that authority over
everything like I I I don't want a bunch
of people voting on how to fix my toilet
no not at all I voting on anything no my
my toilet breaks and then we're like
okay everybody we're going to we got a
broken toilet so let's put it on the
internet and everybody all around gets
to vote on how we fix the toilet but no
I want to hire a plumber who's the best
of the job yeah but what maybe I'm Mis
misrepresenting what I what I'm thinking
I just like is if you could make a bill
and be like this Bill gets funds for a
better process of toilet repair what do
you guys all think and it's like a
Tinder where people like I'll swipe
right on that one I'm swiping left I
right right that's that's that's that's
like suggesting the community vote on
how to fix my toilet but then well we
would just vote on on a bill that we
could send to the Senate and then the
Senate would be like that's idiotic no
and they shoot us down if it's terrible
like they so so so you're basically just
saying you want to eliminate Congress or
I'm sorry eliminate the house I kind of
want a legitimate fourth branch of
government I'm I'm just I don't think
the representatives can handle the load
it's too many people that they're
unrepresented the problem that you're
articulating isn't that there are too
many it's not that they can't handle the
load it's that the load that's being put
on the on the government is too great
for the structure of government so our
government is not supposed to be in the
daily working of your life the federal
government at least right so like the
fact that we have like that the fact
that there was ever a question about who
goes into which bathroom that was at a
federal level is a is exemplary of or
exemplifies exactly what our problem is
we don't need the federal government to
to make every decision for us you don't
even need the state governments to do it
honestly but that's where kind of that's
kind of how society's knee-jerk reaction
is become and I think really like no on
you're right on that point I think
that's a big part of the problem it's
like people have we you you've got I
think generations of people who have
been raised to think that federal
government is the solution and it's not
it's usually the problem and I don't
think our Founders wanted I think our
Founders I know they wanted limited
government because they they've seen
what it can do right and so you know I
think that's that's what some folks in
DC right now are trying to do um you
know it's why we fought so hard to
change out our leadership this year
because we we just continued to head
head down the same path that we were on
and you know like the fight we got back
into January I know you guys had Matt on
your show and you you you've had him in
the past I mean that that fight hadn't
happened what happened in January hadn't
happened in over a hundred years it was
Kevin McCarthy yeah well let let me let
let me pull this story up I I want I got
some questions for you wait that was we
got this from we have this story from
ABC News Kevin McCarthy resigning from
Congress after being Ed to house speaker
so the this story came out yesterday at
the end of the month he will resign he
says I've decided to depart the house at
the end of this year to serve America in
new ways this is really funny because uh
there was a tweet it was a video of uh
was a tweet from him saying I will not
quit and it is now Community noted on
Twitter saying he just quit brutal so uh
here's the funny thing this came out
last night nobody cared yeah yeah nobody
nobody cared that uh former speaker just
announced his resignation but uh I think
what Matt Gates did was fantastic I'm
curious uh your thoughts uh rep cran on
what went down and whether you think
this is all good bad well yeah I mean
obviously Matt deserves a lot of credit
Matt would you know took uh I think took
the brunt of that for sure but there
were eight of us right there were eight
Republicans that moved against our own
speaker um and so for sure I think that
it was a good idea because I was one of
them right um and and the reason the
reason guys like I like I said is
because I didn't get in I didn't get
into this I don't leave my family three
weeks out of the month with my two young
daughters because I like Washington DC
or I like putting on a suit or I ever
wanted to be called a congressman right
I I'm terrified with what my kids are
going to be left with and I look at the
trajectory we're on and it's not
sustainable this house of cards is going
to collapse and PE most people up there
don't take it seriously it's it's it's
weird man it's dystopian there's there's
there's two trains of thought on that I
think everybody agrees the House of
Cards is going to collapse and then
you've got some Republicans who are like
guys let's try and fix this and then
you've got I'd say most Republicans and
Democrats being like how much can we
loot from the coffers before the before
the cards come crashing down yeah we and
we call it the unip party up there right
right anytime anytime something serious
needs to get moved the unip party moves
in lock step and it is Republicans and
Democrats people get pissed at me all
Republicans get pissed at me all the
time you know I'll get calls from donors
or why is Eli why are you why are you
attacking Republicans you know you need
to be attack you need to be fighting
against Democrats that's just one layer
to the fight it is an important layer to
the fight but it goes It goes a lot
deeper than that and if we don't if we
don't acknowledge the own you know the
own stink the own you know our own
problems within our own party this
thing's never going to get it's never
going to get fixed and you know it's
like I I'm just glad that there are
there are people up there who I've seen
even in this last Congress the 118th
Congress who repeatedly are willing to
throw caution to the wind put their
political career career on on the
chopping block and be like hey let's go
let's do something that's never been
done and let's buck the system and so
you know I don't know where that leads
Tim I I'm not I'm not a super optimistic
guy my faith isn't in the federal
government for good reason but uh you
know I I do think it's important I mean
Matt Matt was talking about this billion
doll IOU machine that Kevin McCarthy
builds up where he goes all these all
these donors basically get get our hey
we're going to give money to your pack
we're going to help you get reelected
you're going to control uh uh basically
the Republican party and in the house
and then when he gets Ed all those IUS
become toilet paper so you know this
this machine of favors and DC gets
shattered I got to imagine Kevin
McCarthy was sweating bullets the whole
time because he's not going to be able
to pay back any of these favors he's an
indentured servant for the rest of his
life yeah I honestly don't know and like
you know here's the thing like if you if
you met Kevin and you hung out with him
and you didn't know he was the speaker
of the house you'd probably be like this
guy's pretty cool like I'd have a beer
with him you know and uh uh but that
being said when you look at when you
look at what was going on and when you
look at how he was leading the the party
there there was no desire to change
course at all I've heard from too many
people that he backstabbed their
campaigns that there were there were uh
populists America first they were Trump
supporting for sure and and and any
anybody in that not I shouldn't say
anybody but most people in that spot
would use their power and influence to
back candidates that are going to fall
in line and do what you're told and you
know it's like that's one of the biggest
knock I'm a military guy that's one of
the biggest knocks on Military guys um I
remember when I started going up to DC
Tim some of the older Republicans looked
at me and they're like you know Eli you
military guys get up here and you you
don't really fight too hard you know you
kind of just fall in line and do what
you're told and I I said I know um but
that's when you look at your chain of
command as the people back home the
750,000 people that sent you there
it it's it's you know it's it's
different than seeing the Republican
party or the Democrat Party as your new
chain of command right and that's the
problem with too many politicians they
see they see their party as their chain
of command and they just fall in lock
step and they do what they're told how's
uh life with Mike Johnson the new
speaker how's it been I mean honestly
we're not it's it's not it's really not
uh that much different in that we're
still pretty much on the same trajectory
Maybe a couple degrees off um and I
think that most of us that were involved
in Ting Kevin with the motion to vacate
um beli that that's how it was going to
be just because whoever speaker is
really a representative of the party and
the party is not conservative it's just
not you know um that being said you know
he has done a couple he has done a
couple good things and so like when he
released some of the January 6 tapes I
think that was a good that was a good
thing I I think you know he's serious
about moving forward with you know this
Biden you know impeachment that's a good
thing but he's shown with you know the
CR the continuing resolution that funds
the government at the same levels and
even right now with the ndaa and fisa
that you know we're probably going to
continue to go on on the same path with
some of those things is it because if he
just was like I'm going to make a bill
of getting rid of the CR that everyone
in the party be like then no one's going
to vote for it dude so he has so what
they do you know what they do is they
scare they scare anybody that gets into
leadership right like the intelligence
Community right now is telling Mike
Johnson hey if you let if you let fisa
lapse or you you reform it and and fisa
goes down for even a little while and
you have right now who who's out there
saying that we have more terrorist
threats than we ever have before
Christopher Ray right so so Mike's
making these decisions the intelligence
Community is scaring the snot out of him
saying hey man if you let fisa lapse um
and there's a terrorist attack the
blood's on your hands and that's what
they do constantly up there it's it's
constantly like if you try and change
things whether it's with spending or a
government shutdown or you know making
adjustments or reforming fisa they have
a way to scare you back into into line
not only they going to blame you but
they're going to not only are they going
to blame you but they're going to go
ahead and they're going to accuse you of
trying to make it so that these things
can happen no I I think it's worse than
that you're probably right I think it's
worse than that when uh when when was it
Chuck Schumer said that the intelligence
agencies have six ways from Sunday from
coming after you Donald Trump and then
they accused Trump of being a Soviet spy
no I'm not no Soviet literally from the
80s the guy the guy Jonathan CH goes on
MSNBC and says Trump may have been an
asset of the Russians since the 80s they
they they do multiple impeachments they
do criminal charges everything you you
see them throwing at Trump then I don't
think they go to Mike Johnson and they
say look we got security issues don't
let us down I think they they sit down
at the desk and they say how's it going
how's the family I I got something for
you and they plot a picture of JFK and
they slide it across the table and say
how you doing yeah can you imagine that
like literally all they have to do is
slide a picture of JFK if someone from
CIA shows up at your house and they
slide a picture of JFK across the table
at you and say how you doing like
everyone's sweating everyone starts
sweating yeah they slide a picture of
JFK that's it they don't got to say
anything yeah the implic it's the
implication and I'm not saying the
implication is true I'm just saying you
know it says a lot so the intelligence
when you say the intelligence how do you
phrase it the intelligence Network or
the commun community is that who's
running our government well I I don't
think it's that simplistic I think it's
a mixed it's a mixed bag right there's a
lot there's a lot of different
influences on the government right you
also have your lobbyists your special
interest groups right you have you have
outside Global influences that are
obviously affecting our government as
well um I mean there's it's not as
simplistic as one you know entity um you
know basically running our government
what is a special interest I hear this
stupid word so it's just a business it's
a corporation oh absolutely what about
the pharmaceutical industry green piece
and they so special interest is like a
way to spin it to make just specially
interesting no no no special interest is
an umbrella term for a variety of
organizations that want a specific goal
to to be met so Green Peace is
not you say but they want the same goal
no no no no lock Martin is a special
interest group they Lobby on behalf of
themselves Green Piece it's a special
special interest group they Lobby on
behalf of themselves no one's going to
sit there and be like the problem we
have is let me pull out 18,000 pages of
every single organization ever that's
lobbying the government special interest
groups powerful organizations from the
private and public sector and nonprofits
that are lobbying government to make
things happen some are more powerful
than others and then if they say it's a
lobbyist that could be just a guy but if
it's a special interest group it's a
lobbyist the lobbyist would be the
individual that's actually trying to get
the politician to do whatever it is that
the the that the special interest group
wants the group is the special interest
the lobbyist the individual yeah and to
be fair I mean there there are there are
good lobbyist right that are lobbying
for good things but often times you know
it's uh you know it Ventures into
corruption and you know seeking things
that are so front sight focus on just
taking care of one industry sa Ian you
my firearms guy got it over here you and
I will I will and I will do it again so
when when you when you talk to someone
who's in Congress and you're like you
got to get graphine I was about to say
that we were talking about the house of
cards we need to graphine lattice to
reinforce the Ian Lobby it's carbon it's
carbon powder basically uh you make it
from any kind of carbon and they figur
out already on the gra you get like
plastic trash and hit it with 7,000 de
electricity too far ahead it's like 21st
century steel it's going to be the next
big building material it's it's it's a
one-dimensional sheet of carbon
hexagonally LED which has amazing
properties when manipulated so well can
it's a superconductor yes and capacitor
you can use it as like a touchscreen
battery wallpaper um they put it in in
car well I'll give you the real simple
so Ian's obsessed with this stuff but
the the reason I brought it up was to
make the point that lobbying a lot of
people have this view of lobbying as
this like prestigious thing and it's
like dude it literally means you argued
to a member of Congress yeah stand in
the lobby literally that's why they that
after then when they came out of the
proceeding they'd be like hey for the
sake of Ian's griffine uh one thing they
they started doing is they put it in
batteries okay and so what that does is
when you're charging a battery the
graphine carries the charge evenly
across the battery so it charges rapidly
so uh uh I think the newer cell phones
that come out could could charge to full
in like 10 minutes wow so you can you
can buy these graphine Polymer batteries
you you ever get one of those mobile
batteries you buy the Walgreens whatever
plug your phone in yeah they now they
now have graphine uh lithium batter
batteries that you can charge that
battery pack in 15 minutes and it'll
give your phone 2 hours of charge wow
you can put it in concrete and it'll
make it three times stronger you can put
it in like this is just bulk graphine
where you shatter it into powder you can
also make sheets of it like Tim was
talking about they can be used as
Electronics which is more complicated to
produce at the moment and this is
literally lobbying but what I really
want to sell you on is hydrogen fuel
because if we if we want to reinforce
that house of cards we need a new GDP
model and it's I think it's based on
hydrogen fortunately you can turn the
oil into graphine so we don't have to
upend the oil industry maybe I I don't
know I think Fusion Energy is is
promising reach ignition now we just got
to capture that energy so and nuclear
but out of rice they're making hydrogen
fuel like crazy right now with carbon
trash they'll hit it with a laser they
produce a kilogram of hydrogen fuel and
then they have $4.50 left over of this
stuff so it's actually profitable to
create the hydrogen W let's let's let's
jump to this story so we can get get
into what happened last night with the
GOP debates the ramaswami I love this
one defends debunked conspiracy theories
he shared at Republican debate he
elevated false F or groundless claims
about January 6 us demographic changes
here's the crazy thing this is what
really really bothers me these guys who
work for ABC News I assume they're
either uh really really stupid or
intentionally lying January 6
definitively without question provably
and adjudicated as such is an inside job
next question and and and I'll clarify
now because I know I tried to hammer
that one really really hard several
individuals had already have have been
acquitted because the judge outright
said police welcomed them in there's
video of police opening the doors and
letting people in the response we've
gotten is oh well you got to understand
why they did it okay explain to me why
the Q Shaman was given a guided tour
they walk to a door try to open it it
doesn't open then they bring him they
bring the guy to the Senate chambers the
argument is they were overwhelmed they
had no choice they just gave in like the
cop who took a selfie there's more than
one cop who took selfies with people
opened these doors there are doors that
have are are mag sealed you know this
better than I do they're maglock you
can't just open them someone has to De
deactivate the electric current to open
the door somebody did this Alexandre
okazi Cortez was actually one of the
first I probably not one of the first
but of Democrats she actually said and
this is like a year and a half ago there
were police officers who are Fanning
people in moving barricades opening
doors and she wants answers I'm like I
completely agree those those are facts
so I'll say it this way the media is
claiming ramas Swami statements was were
debunked the said it now looks like it
may have been an inside job here's the
game they're playing they're conflating
inside job with Joe Biden was involved
or Nancy Pelosi was involved here's
here's how here's how I I'll put it for
you a thousand people work at a bank one
day the bank gets robbed two guys who
worked there opened the doors for the
robbers who then made off that's called
an inside job to the degree to which the
guys were involved who knows they may
have gotten a phone call and they said
hey look we're going to slip you a $100
bill just open the door for us and
they're like sure I guess I don't even
know what's going on still an inside job
Inside Job refers to someone on the
inside facilitated what happened so
while you have people fighting with cops
on one side you have cops opening other
doors and letting people in he also and
uh well he also talked about great
replacement and this is what really got
people all riled up is that he basically
said it was policy for Democrats so uh
instead of getting ahead of myself I
want to we we we'll stick it to the
we'll stick to the January 6 first and
then we'll get into the other other
portion the V said why am I the only
person on the stage at least who can say
that January 6 now does look like it was
an inside job they say that baseless
idea has become popular among fringes on
the far right and social on social media
at times even winning support from
lawmakers including Senator Mike Lee who
last month claimed without evidence that
there were undercover federal agents
disguised in the crowd during the
rioting at the US capital as Congress
had gathered to certify Trump's election
defeat well I'm curious your thoughts uh
on all this I don't know if there were
federal agents i' I've heard that
claimed I don't know if you know
anything about it yeah I I do believe
there were federal agents as well um and
I believe we had Christopher Ray in a
Homeland Security uh Committee hearing I
think two two weeks ago and when asked
that question he basically gave the
tagline you know I'm not going to
comment on any you know um any operation
any investig ongoing investigation type
type deal I I actually asked one of the
questions I asked him uh was hey why
hasn't the pipe bomber been caught right
I found that fascinating that and the
way kind of the way I posed the question
to him was so how many how many people
did you guys arrest at January 6th and
it was I don't know hundreds and
hundreds of people right the one the one
guy that could have you know basically
created multiple mass casualty events
with his pipe bombs meaning killed or
injured you know you know dozens and
dozens of people um you know just they
the FBI can't find that guy and I just
it just it's wild to be because DC is
one of DC is one of the most heavily
fortified
defended um and recorded cities you know
um in the entire country and so you're
telling me that you know and and maybe
this maybe this is you know too
conspiratorial for some but it just
strikes me as odd that the this guy he
couldn't um he was so proficient that
he's able to avoid the most proficient
law enforcement organization in the
world yet he couldn't get his pipe bombs
to go off right and or people are
arguing oh well they got them before you
know they got the pipe bombs before they
were you know set to go off I just I'm
sorry man I don't buy that this guy has
been avoiding you know the FB bi I also
when I look at guys like Ray EPS the
fact that Ray EPS was in the crowd he
was M seen multiple times he's caught on
camera multiple times telling people we
got to go into the building we got we
got to go into the capital and years
into this he's not arrested even though
you know guys on like revolver news you
know the guys at revolver continually
reporting on this stuff it just stinks
to high heaven and then you got that
right on the back end of the you know
Michigan deal with Gretchen Gretchen
Whitmer
I I I think the FBI has you know needs
to be reeled in and it's why many of us
tried to deny them the ability to uh get
their new FBI headquarters probably
about a month and a half ago and once
again the uni party moved in lockstep to
give them their new I think it was like
$300 million building in DC no it's not
going to be in DC I can't remember where
it is it it is uh it's amazing to me
that they're able to um track down a
garage pull rope remember that one yeah
the uh who who who who was that guy B
Bubba Wallace or Bubba yeah yeah it was
a garage pup I can't remember his name
said a dozen agents so last year we were
uh swatted we had uh we we had um I
don't like using the phrase swatted
because people don't understand what
that means let's just say uh swatting
like events 15 times and I'll clarify a
couple of them were fake bomb uh
bombings and so uh this ranges from I
think it was
it was like actually it was like four or
five two of them were physical devices I
shouldn't say devices were physical
objects that were sent here and i' I've
only somewhat disclosed this before and
so the they sent a robot out they got
this uh they have this device it's like
I don't know if it's an x-ray or
whatever but they uh try and blast the
box to see what's inside of it and
whoever whoever did this knew the
capabilities of law
enforcement and OB structed the view of
the device that seeks to look inside the
Box externally right they put a panel
behind it like a reflective panel and
they blast it with like x-ray or
something and they said we can't get in
so we're bringing the robots in we also
had to we were forced to evacuate the
building for three hours and the stream
went live to like 50,000 people for
three hours with a Deb nothing in the
room they never they never caught these
guys we've been we've had uh police sent
here on numerous fake calls some were
actual humans a human voice some were uh
uh robotic and they never catch these
guys but pull rope and even even after
we submitted a bunch of evidence and
told them like guys like this
information may like we've we've got
evidence they just said we don't care at
all well if you were at a if you were a
concerned parent at a school board
meeting Tim I bet your issue would be I
bet they your issue would be resolved
man you mean if you were a liberal
parent concerned about conservatives
complaining yeah your your your issue
would be resolved y this pipe bomb thing
at the capital
is always kind of fascina me in that it
hasn't been talked about that much like
I heard about it was there actual did
they produce the pipe bombs was there
evidence that did they show them and be
like these are what we found and then
like show evidence that it was they were
legitimately found was there any
evidence of them like recording finding
them or any of that yeah there there's
there's video footage of them you know I
think retrieving the pipe bombs but cuz
it it adds it heightens the the danger
of the day knowing that there were bombs
placed so that it wouldn't I mean it
doesn't it wouldn't surprise me if
people came out later like yeah you know
we did that to intensify the the fear so
that we could shut it down quicker like
I think a lot of this is like let's just
get it put I mean it if you told me they
had no FBI agents in in the crowd that
day I'd be kind of disappointed with the
FBI you're going to do a riot on the
capital and you don't have FBI agents
out there like looking at stuff you get
your get your agents on the field I mean
let's let's address down like let's just
say they were caught off guard and
there's a bunch of there's there's
250,000 Trump supporters marching around
the feds had no one no no that that's
that's an absurdity I'm sorry they knew
well in advance yo I'm some dude who
just complains on the internet and I
read a Fox news story that Trump was
calling for protest I was like wow
that's going to be crazy yeah Media
Matters ran a hitpiece on me claiming
that I had four knowledge because I said
something in November where I was like
yo these proud boys and 3centers or
whatever are going to like stor are rush
to DC and like storm the White House or
something like they're not going to
accept a trump defeat literally did
happen didn't happen in November it was
January way later I had no idea it was
speculation based on news reports if I
can speculate that you mean the FBI
didn't actually have any plan for
security or undercover uh agents to be
there that's the one I'm thinking about
Ray apps cuz when that when that was the
one thing when I first was like like a
lightning bolt like what the when he was
screaming for people to go to the build
go in the building and then he didn't
get arrested I was like what in the hell
like at least arrest him and do like a
dog and pony show to make it look like
he was one of the bad guys can can I
just point this out isn't it crazy that
we this is a story from the New York
Post isn't it crazy that it was March of
2023 two years more than two years later
we got the footage showing Capital coll
Capital cops escorting the QQ on Shaman
to the senate floor how was that not
disclosed immediately especially
considering they they're locking they
locked this guy up or they at the time
they were about to lock him up you see
this video where they're actually
walking him to the doors and opening the
doors for him yeah
I'm sorry that's an inside job yeah and
it's like maybe they didn't want a
prolong Siege of the building they
didn't want all the windows to get
broken out so like just get it over with
get in here but that they're arresting
for trespassing he like dude there's a
video where a cop walks in he's like can
you guys please leave and I think it's
the shaman he's like we'll take care of
it we'll be nice yo they let him in in
the first place if he was if he was
being that nice they didn't even need to
open the door for him they could have
been like buddy no you got to go and he
would have been like okay the dude's
bumbling around and they're guiding him
to these places I did a show with with
Michael M and Jacob Chanley the guy
we're talking about so he's out of jail
I don't know what his what happened did
he serve the full sentence I was trying
to look up I asked him if it was what
solitary was like it hor on Earth let's
do this let's talk about the other
component of uh what VI ramas Swami said
that's triggering all of these people in
media and that is uh what do they say
false us demographic changes so they go
on to bring up the great replacement
Theory and I love how they do this ABC
news says ramas Swami also boosted the
great replacement Theory the white
nationalist belief that immigration
policies are designed specifically to
dilute the political power of white
Americans by making them a smaller share
of the population the idea has been
elevated by media figures like Tucker
Carlson and inspired Mass violence in
2015 Charleston South uh Carolina church
Massacre and in the 2019 shooting at
Walmart ramas Swami alleged during the
debate that the theory is not some Grand
right-wing conspiracy theory but a basic
statement of the democratic party
platform how about I just play this
video of Van Jones for you and we'll
start breaking this down asking the
white majority to do something as
difficult and I think it'd be easier if
we just acknowledge that it's difficult
no ethnic majority group in 10,000 years
of human history that I can find ever
went from being a m majority to being a
minority and lik it and that's basically
the request from the racial Justice left
is that we want the white majority to go
from being a majority to being a
minority and like it that's a tough
request and the reality is it change is
hard change that you want is hard change
that is good as hard so the racial
Justice left according to him is asking
the white majority to go from being a
majority to a minority there's only two
ways that happens one Mass migration and
white people not having kids if they're
asking white people to do this they are
outright saying we want a policy of mass
migration and we don't want you to have
kids there's a third way it's
genocide well right right right I
suppose you know in my context I'm
talking about what's currently going on
right now in this country twoth peaceful
ways to do it but we have this this
great article from Newsweek Democrats
are massive Hypocrites on so-called
great replacement Theory and this is by
Pedro Gonzalez from 2022 in Newsweek
where he breaks down statements from Joe
Biden and many other Democrats where
they're outright basically saying this
they're outright saying it uh he says
the mass shooting in Buffalo New York
was an atrocity the killer will pay for
his life the suspect left by
180 page document outlining a
schizophrenic worldview we get that
Biden and the company latched onto it
but here's the problem Democrats and
Progressive activists based on their own
rhetoric over the years subscribe to
replacement Theory more than anyone else
as Vice President Biden himself said
that a constant and unrelenting stream
of immigration would reduce Americans of
white European stock to an absolute
minority and that was a source of our
strength I'm not going to go through the
whole article because Pedro actually
brings up a ton of other excellent
examples but I think right there when
when you have Joe Biden who is now the
president saying a source of our
strength is an unrelenting stream of
immigration reducing white Americans to
a minority yeah I'm going to go ahead
and say like uh the's not wrong well he
took three quotes out of context and
stuffed them all together into one
sentence so I I would like to see I'm
not saying Joe Biden's not a racist but
I would like to see the full context of
those those statements and also now when
we talk about great replacement I think
it should be repurposed to be like you
know we're not it's not designed to
specifically the power of the white
Americans it's designed to dilute the
power of citizens of the American
citizens that's what's happening that's
the problem yeah I think it is bigger I
think it is bigger in many ways but I
also think this I mean this has all the
Hallmarks of cultural Marxism right
there you go cultural Marxism is
designed to topple the cultural hity or
whoever is perceived to be at the top
you know it's interesting I started
studying this a couple years ago there's
a you know a pastor named Dr VOD bacham
he he's a big black dude that looks like
he could play he was a he was a football
player on the rise and then he became a
pastor and he does this phenomenal
Series in sermon on cultural Marxism and
how he went on CNN one time they invited
him on after Obama took the White House
and he said that the anchor was
basically asking Dr bacham hey uh do you
think that race relations in the US are
going to get better now that we have a
black president and um VOD bacham said
no I they're going to get worse and it
surprised the anchor and VOD bacham went
on to say it's going to get worse
because um Obama set under a cultural
Marxist Pastor named Jeremiah Wright for
a very long time and if he goes back and
he he he you know kind of gives a
history lesson about cultural Marxism
and and how they tried you know Marxism
to destroy the West traditional Marxism
where you you pit people against each
other economically right you have the
halves and the have knots well that
didn't work here in the west because
everybody was too prosperous so what
they do they just reversed they they
just made a slight change to the
ingredients instead of dividing us all
up on you know economic classes we're
just going to divide them all up by race
and it's working tremendously I mean if
you go and you look at how divided we
are on Race you know and it's just to me
it's just disgusting like but you know
when I when I listen to Van Jones right
there you know and what he's saying
about um you know I want white you know
what what I want for white people and to
go from being you know on top of things
or what what do you say Tim from being
the majority majority to being the
minority and to like it that has to me
all the Hallmarks of cultural Marxism
the statement itself is not just an
explanation of what they're doing but an
attempt at incitement to to trigger
reactions which they can then use to
take to gain more power and take
advantage of this you have van Jones
outright saying the racial I don't know
if he's saying I but he does say the
racial Justice left is asking white
people to become a minority which Ian
does bring up there is a third way but
in American politics there's Mass
migration and and birth control advocacy
against having kids and things like this
that's actively happening and so van
Jones saying
that then gets people on the right
people like Vivic ramaswami to be like
hey this is the something Democrats have
espoused and then the media immediately
comes out and says they're conspiracy
theorists and they're racists they're
white and they're Nazis yeah to Ian's
point though I think it's even bigger
than you know the the replacement stuff
and I do think that's a part of it but
you know he said they're trying it's
almost like they're trying to destroy it
right I think they try and destroy this
country every way they possibly can cuz
I don't think they like the country I
don't think that I think that they want
it changed I think that they they want a
top down totalitarian control they want
it to you know be some Utopia that has
you know a little bit of socialism
little bit of communism in it and as
long as we as long as Americans feel
free prosperous we we have a
constitution we have the ability to
defend ourselves we have freedom of
speech all of that stands in their way
and so I think that it's Death By A
Thousand Cuts and I think that that's
why it just feels like we're living in
Bizarro land Patrick Bet David talks a
lot about uh choosing your enemies
wisely which I think is fascinating
because I'm like I don't have any
enemies I don't want to have any enemies
but I'm like who's my enemy think about
today CCP I'm not sure I don't want my
enemies to be you or like Alexandria
kazio Cortez who represents the
Democratic party in a way that you know
I find admirable in some ways at least
it's youthful but like I don't want my
enemies to be in our country but I and
then I'm like am I just being xenophobic
but do you think the CCP is is involved
in in in this
Marxist obliteration of American
culturalism wasn't do you think that the
CCP the Communist Chinese party the
that's as far as I'll go do you think
that they're like the masterminds of
this no no it's it doesn't take a person
so like the it's an ideology so like you
know how like if you go to a Catholic
mass right like if you go to a Catholic
mass in the US and then one in you know
in somewhere in South America they're
going to be similar because Catholicism
has stuff that you are supposed to do to
be Catholic the leftist ideology that he
outlines and I he's 100% right in my
opinion um the leftist ideology that he
outlines like
there are there is a whole you know
structure that that people follow so it
doesn't matter that that you don't need
a person that's top Downing it right
they're they they believe in an ideology
and so if you believe in the ideology
you follow the tenants that are the of
the ideology and you don't need someone
to one particular person to dictate to
you because you do the things that
marxists do you look at the world
through a Marxist lens that just
intensifies the value of the culture War
like if it's if it's an in like an
innate emergent phenomenon that's
spreading like wildfire on the internet
there needs to be a better Wildfire it's
not so much emergent it is it is people
that believe it that are telling other
people right now the the conduit has
been basically the the um the academy
basically schools have been Academia
like have you guys you guys have I'm
sure watched the Yuri bof videos oh yeah
yeah where he talks about um you know
ideological subversion right and he's
like I mean if you watch these videos I
mean what Tim when do you think those
were made like the 9s 80 it was the 80s
yeah the ' 80s this guy was in the US at
this time um KGB Defector you know
saying that you know you silly Americans
you think that you know the KGB we spent
most of our resources on ESP James Bond
Espionage because it's sexy and it's in
the movies he's like no only about maybe
15% of our budget went to that stuff
right most of it went to ideological
subversion you know putting people in
your institutions your cold culture
Academia and teaching this crap these
ideologies and and and I think that's
what that's what you're seeing right now
but I I think the uh I've had this
debate 800,000 times actually but I
think the the actual issue was big Tech
and social media and it's not uh so much
the universities I think I think the
universities are a component obviously
because you see all these videos where
someone sends their kids to college and
their kid comes back angry shaved head
you know weird tattoos and things like
that face tattoos or whatever right but
uh what we're saying with the rise of uh
cultural Marxism and things like this
started around the world all around the
same time which is more indicative of
social media creating the phenomenon
than anything else and there's actually
uh a simple explanation so uh the early
social media algorithms favor anything
that makes people angry and so you had
uh Libertarians and I think even like uh
Paul Joseph Watson and like Alex Jones
were posting police brutality videos cuz
it got people riled up they'd watch the
video and then complain about it right
and so if you're a right libertarian
you're complaining about the same stuff
that eventually black lives matter
started complaining about but what
happens police bralia on its own only
gets 100,000 views racist police
brutality gets a million views so the
algorithm started favoring content that
pushed things like racism is bad
homophobia is bad anything that would
seem like an injustice and then you had
um the example I always cite is mike.com
which started off as like a Ron Paul
libertarian website turned into a
leftist Social Justice website because
of social media gorithms you write an
article that's in favor of right
libertarian anti-government it does okay
you write a social justice piece it's
got racist sexist anti-gay in the title
bang it's getting a million views so the
company starts putting all their
resources into hiring writers to write
all that stuff and then instantly around
the world you see this in the Lexus
Nexus data every country experiences
except for like Iran and North Korea
they have weird fluctuations but almost
every single country with access to the
basic internet we do sees the same rise
in racism privilege intersection ality
feminism Etc all rapidly happening at
the exact same time yeah I uh when I was
started making internet videos in 06 I I
would make a video called like we are
all the same and like if you believe you
are then you are like that kind of
mindset it was it was that Mark it that
weird post-modernist thing and they
would they do really well the videos
would do really well with like and the
people that were watching them I don't
know all of them but I think a lot of
them were suffering in their lives so it
sounded good to like yes we are all the
same but we're not we're all similar but
we're not all the same but that that's
that just resonates so powerfully when
you say something like that with
confidence especially if you're someone
that people like that they aspire to be
like and so that I see why communism
constantly Cycles back around it's like
we are all we can all do this together
until we get there and then somebody's
got to be in charge yeah like right back
to the center so I I saw those videos
online like should I take them down or
should I leave them up I I won't take
them down but I think leave them up so
people can watch my train of thought
change over the decades yeah and I think
I I don't know where I learned it if I
learned it in high school
like obsessive empathy too much
compassion what it was I don't know
where it came from man but it was just
it was through Me growing
Up we've got uh we got breaking news
this actually uh broke about an hour ago
but we'll get into it right now from ABC
special prosecutor files nine tax
related felony charges against Hunter
Biden special councel David David Weiss
has filed additional charges uh Let me
refresh to get the L information the
indictment uh the in the indictment
prosecutors alleged Hunter Biden engaged
in a 4-year scheme to not pay at least
1.4 million in self- assessed federal
taxes he owed for the year's 2016
through 19 from in or uh from in or
about January 2017 to October 15 2020
and to evade the assessment of taxes for
tax year 2018 when he filed false
returns in or about February 2020 is
this how they bring down Joe Biden about
Joe Biden that's how they got uh taxes
is how they got Al Capone right but I'm
want I I'm not saying this right here
here is how they get Joe Biden I'm
saying this is in relation to one by one
you get these death by Thousand Cuts of
Hunter Biden and then eventually someone
goes hey wait a minute one of these
threads goes to Joe and then Joe EMB
battled says look I'm going to step down
you know these allegations are false but
that's you saw the MSNBC clip where they
they're they're interviewing Joe Biden
they're asking questions like so what do
you have to say about this these
conversations you've had with Hunters
Associates when you were lying he's like
uh it's it's not true you're lying
you're all lies you're all lying you're
all liars dogf face Pony soldiers all
you to answer your question Tim yes I
think this is the track they're going
after the bidens now and then maybe
they'll use the same kind of tax crap to
go after Trump I don't know if they are
they hitting them on tax charges let me
let me let's let's pul this clip because
it's kind of crazy to see here's a clip
of uh Joe Biden being questioned on
MSNBC on Ukraine and also China uh there
is polling by the Associated Press that
shows that almost 70% of Americans
including 40% of Democrats
believe that you acted either illegally
or unethically in regards to your
family's business interest can you
explain to the Americans uh to Americans
admit this impeachment inquiry why you
interacted with so many of your son and
brothers foreign business associates I'm
not going to comment that I did not and
it's just a bunch of Lies didn't
interact
with comment isn't it I did not there
lies did not I keep hearing Tommy I 7%
40% of Democrats think he acted
illegally that's MSNBC saying this
that's crazy man I I don't see how Biden
ends up the nominee I you know I don't
either but at the same time because I
know that you know they're all about
that what what's their goal their goal
is power right so I I've always thought
that he's the perfect front man for for
what they're doing because as they
destroy the country systematically they
got the perfect Fall Guy out there the
guy can't put together together a
sentence he falls
constantly um they've got a ton of
clearly a ton of dirt on him so he's got
to do what they say and he wanted to
he's wanted to be president forever so
it's like why and when he's when he when
when the as the country collapses on his
watch they can they can blame him you
know so I think he's the perfect Fall
Guy but I wouldn't be surprised to see
the old bait and switch and see a guy
like Nome get thrown in there either so
we'll see what happens man but I wonder
what the prediction markets have new at
right now I'm going to check Actually I
don't even know which one's wor I don't
even know what what would be worse for
the country honestly I think it's Mr
surrender Afghanistan is probably worse
he this guy surrendered the most
powerful military on Earth to the
Taliban and and $80 billion worth of
equipment he surrendered how many people
died over there in that surrender 19
people died in the bomb that went off
and and women throwing their babies
trying to throw their babies over barb
wire to get him inside a military base
the babies are getting caught in the
wire like that's because of him he
called he made that call to get rid of
BM Air Force Base air superiority and
just left everybody in the Lurch with
the rushed surrender the most terrible
military executive I've ever seen in
power in the United States I I agree but
I don't you know a lot of people think
Biden's in charge or someone's pulling
the leash I'm kind of like no I think
they're letting him flounder they're
sitting back watching it just letting it
roll out because like you said when it
all comes crashing down they want to
burn it down they want to replace it
with something else they just blame
Biden and then he's gone he's he's there
he's there he's their py perfect Fall
Guy but but you're right that is I mean
it is scary it's it's one of Afghanistan
was definitely one of the uh you know
big massive failures I I was in the SEAL
Teams for a little bit and uh and one of
the things that scared me or concerned
me when I was looking at the list of
gear Left Behind was all the night
vision goggles because you know as as
when you're operating overseas a lot of
times we we would almost exclusively
operate at night because we own the
night right but now that these guys have
all that night vision equipment that's
going to make it really difficult for
any of our troops or any of our allies
that are fighting at night and you know
that definitely takes our superiority
and our advantage down I don't know how
like how many they actually left but you
know that they're not staying in
Afghanistan either it's getting into uh
combat zones all over the world and like
I mean anybody that's got you know
played around with night vision it is a
completely different thing to be able to
see at night when when the people that
you're going after can't see at no look
I think most City people I I I I there's
a lot of people listening right now who
are going to be like n Tim's most City
people don't know what nighttime is like
yeah so when in that famous story about
La power goes out the police get a bunch
of phone calls about something strange
in the sky it was the first time they
had seen the Milky Way yeah so when the
lights are all out and it's dark so when
we have a a new moon out here where
we're at we have we have light set up on
the side of the driveway we have motion
lights not just for us to be able to see
but for security reasons too but uh I
you you you walk down the driveway
during a new moon it is Pitch Black and
and I'm like you are blind 100% you put
on the night fish and goggles we got and
it is daylight yeah we also have
daylight flashlights which are cool too
though no it's it's true man it's one of
the most surreal
experiences that I've ever had walking
through one of the you know very big
cities some of the most violent cities
in the world um but nobody's on the
streets but you and you know a couple of
your buddies patrolling and it's that's
why it's because we have we have that
technology and they don't and now you
see it left behind like that and it's
just like f the first time you put them
on and you could see satellites it's
crazy yeah it's like it's like the movie
Step Brothers right yeah when you were
you were you in when they had were they
had Panos yeah did you a Pano or you
mean the are you talking binos no no no
the four yeah no I I never had the uh I
never had those I always had the binos
what are the Pinos binos are just two
two or four Panos there's four tubes so
you can actually see a wider range yeah
so when when uh I first first time I
ever used them was actually like two
years ago or whatever I bought a pair
and you look at the sky and it's like
there's a satellite it's insane shooting
stars like they're up there happening
right now and you just oh yeah oh oh
yeah you you're seeing them go shooting
across when you're wearing those things
it's it's nuts and then you're like
walking around like I can see everything
it's crazy how much are those cost how
do we get those those those are $42,000
oh wow how many of those were left were
surrendered do you know off hand roughly
how many he could he could Google it
right now I know it wasn't it wasn't 15
of them it was thousand thousands and
thousand they probably they probably
actually left binos they probably didn't
leave Panos Panos were are the uh the
really high expensive ones only the that
he was on seal that's why I asked
because the SEAL Teams in Delta are the
guys that get Panos every else gets
binos plans guns and night vision I mean
obviously yeah I I don't see how
Afghanistan was an accident how do you
you don't accidentally abandon your Air
Force Base in the middle of the night
without telling your partners yeah yeah
that that that that one's tough to
explain so what do you do in the
military you served it with the seals
like if your commander or orders a
surrender like abruptly that causes Mass
death and and loss of equipment and life
like what happens to that
Commander I guess it depends on who the
leadership at the top is right the
military you know I think for a long
time has been I think for a long time
had been spared from a lot of the
insanity of this culture but even over
the last couple years you've seen you
know it it it you know infect the
military as well like I just we we had a
uh we had an Air Force Admiral in
homeland security I think this last week
and he was talking about um some of
their issues and one of their big issues
was Recruitment and I asked him do you
think it has anything to do with the you
know Dei training do you think it has
anything to do with you know drag shows
on base you know that that type of stuff
they never never really was in the
military um and he's like no he and and
he chocked it up to covid and I asked
him well do you think it has anything to
do with forcing uh our service members
to take an experimental
vaccine um and you know basically he was
he was like well you know I I don't know
about that and I was like do you cuz now
the armed forces are actually offering
these guys that didn't take the vaccine
to come back in yeah right and they said
oh and we'll we'll clear your record
right after they forced them out many of
them had families had to find a new job
you know whatever and and they didn't
get I don't believe they got honorable
discharges right I think it was
administrative wasn't it I I I don't
remember you you you might be right Tim
um but you know I asked him do you think
that had anything to do with it and he's
basically said you know I'm not you know
I'm not uh I'm not able to comment on
that who was that some it was some air
force or I'm sorry not Air Force it was
the Coast Guard Admiral General
discharge under honorable conditions
okay so uh that's that's what I guess is
being reported just so that Admiral
knows if you own up to the truth they'll
be more likely to reinlist yeah it was
because they were forced to take a
vaccine that they didn't trust and they
quit because of it or they were
discharged because of it and now they're
being asked to come back like what have
some humility guy Admiral I well that's
the problem like the military is one of
the most dangerous jobs you can have and
if you if you don't have any faith that
leadership's not going to sell you out
if if you believe that your leadership
will stab you in the back you know so
they can continue to get promoted how
many people do you think are going to
join and that's that's the thing it's
like a lot a lot of these young kids I
mean and I think there's multiple issues
there but a lot of these young kids
don't trust this the leadership that
they just saw you you know be in charge
of the debacle in Afghanistan and that
you know forced a bunch of our troops to
get an experimental vaccine and now that
they can't recruit kids to come back in
you know they're offering hey to bring
them back I mean it's just it's a
complete leadership disaster what do you
think would be a good incentive to get
people
back well I think I think an apology to
start with would be really nice and
these these guys taking ownership and be
like hey we screwed up okay we screwed
up secondly like my little brother
you know when he was a cobra pilot in
the Marine Corps he I think he was on
his last year in the Marine Corps and
was basically told you're getting the
VAC you're getting the vaccine or you're
out and so my little brother went to the
Naval Academy like flew helicopters you
know High performing guy actual actual
officer not war yeah he was he was an O
and uh he lost his retirement cuz he
wouldn't put that in his body and so
take you you got to take care of those
you got to take care of those guys and
then you got to you got to take care of
the the folks that are injured now
because of the vaccine as well and just
make them feel like hey we got your back
because if you don't got my back when it
comes to you know this stuff right here
you I don't I don't think you're going
to have my back when we're going to war
against the CCP or we're going to war
against Iran and and you know I'm I'm
I'm out there by myself and I need some
air support and to the to the point that
you were making earlier about the about
cultural Marxism and stuff the the goal
of that kind of is to shake people's uh
faith and and in the in the our our
system in the United States and so if
you've got you know graduating class
after graduating class after graduating
class being churned out of high schools
and colleges that have been taught that
America's not really all that good
America's not worth fighting for
America's a bad force a force for evil
in the world America's the the the
villain on the global scale normally uh
and generally that's the the the role
that the US has had since the end of
World War II if that's what you've been
taught why would you join the military
to serve the Govern the government right
like there's no reason to I want to do
like a mini segment real quick have you
guys heard about what's going on with
Venezuela and Guyana yeah no what's
happening Venezuela's declaring
ownership of the western portion of the
nation of Guyana and amassing its
military and now Guyana is requesting us
Aid to prevent The Invasion it's over
half of the country that they're making
a claim to it's not just a a small part
socialists want stuff for free and and
so part of reason why they're doing this
is because um xon mobile was just doing
uh Explorations out off the Ghana coast
and so they want to go after after
Ghana's basically their guy guyana's uh
um Ghana and the other kind yeah no my
bad Guyana and Ghana and so they're
going out so it's after the capitalists
have done the exploring to find the oil
reserves that you would only be able to
find with tools provided or invented for
capitalist
exploration and now the Socialist like
yo that's mine but you know that I just
want to say like you've got Middle
Eastern conflict you've got Eastern
European conflict you now have an
escalating together was it you're tying
it together yeah oh yeah now you got
South American conflict and we're
southeast Asia is right on the horizon 2
on fire this would be a World War also
with South with the stuff going on in
South America there is the Monroe
Doctrine that we have to worry about if
there's anyone that decides that they're
going to uh support Venezuela that would
be from the you know from Asia or from
from you know whether it be uh Russia or
China or whatever if they or Iran if
they decide that they want to support
Venezuela then the US has the mono
Doctrine which is saying that no one
from from any other part from the from
the Eastern hemisphere has any business
being in the Western Hemisphere this is
the total the domain totally the domain
of the United States and we will not
accept countries from Europe or from uh
Asia or from the Middle East or from
Africa
meddling in North or South America we
just totally reject it out of hand and
so now the US is in a situation where if
anyone does decide to go ahead and
support Venezuela then the us is going
to talk about the Monroe Doctrine and
say you can't be here I don't think it
even matters if Russia Iran or China
gets involved with Venezuela the fact is
if we have war in South America war in
Southeast Asia war in Eastern Europe War
in the Middle East you've got World
War that's kind of how World War II like
melini started that and with his North
freaking Conquest he gave Hitler the
green light basically he was like Hey
look you can conquer your neighbors and
no one's stopping me and then Hitler was
like o wow I like that and Japan it's
not like these these are neighboring
countries Japan's war was to you do it
which justifies that guy doing it which
justifies that guy doing it and then
you've got like a smash and grab
situation where everyone's like well
before this is over I'm going to see if
I can get a piece maybe not justify but
basically creates the opportunity yeah
justifying their own minds I should say
I mean is there really ever a
justification for offensive War I don't
know yeah but but the SC thing I suppose
is as Phil's bring up with minro
Doctrine is Guyana is asking the US to
prevent The Invasion so what do you guys
think we should we going to get involved
in war in Venezuela I don't think so but
I'd rather have our aircraft carriers
there than in the in ag Red Sea or
something I agree because we're talking
about having our forces in the Gulf all
I can say is I'm missing some Mean
Tweets right about now yeah are you
involved with this kind of the military
stuff in the I mean you know it's like
uh involved in in uh
the function of funding that that's the
power of the purse is probably the
biggest tool that Congress has and so
funding the military and then also
funding you know I would say our our
projects overseas and Foreign Affairs
that that's a lot of congresses and
obviously Congress can declare war as
well but that that doesn't happen too
often in modern times usually since
World War II yeah usually usually uh in
modern times you know you've got your
executive branch that's that's doing
that so the executive takes control of
the military or you know probably
unrighteously but the executive always
has control of the military so once it's
Unleashed it's the executives Authority
until they want to stop does Congress
declare when the war is over or is that
up to the the executive
branch it it can be either or so if
someone's going to decide to move those
aircraft carriers away from Israel into
the off the coast of Venezuela without
be president right that's the president
yeah that's the president making those
calls Joe Biden he's like what's it
called again I they're talking about
Hunter they're lies it's all lies no sir
we're talking about Venezuela going to
war you're lying you're all lying all
right everybody we're going to go to
Super Chat so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.net you don't want to miss it
and you get access to the Discord server
to hang out with like-minded individuals
who put on pre-shows after shows and if
you're in the Discord you can submit
questions and call in to talk to us and
our guests all right we got user M the
first Super Chat of the night
congratulations saying first join the
Discord Trump
2024 right on kalishnikov says why don't
you cover the NZ whistleblower don't
know enough about it have you guys heard
about this he released a uh uh covid
data I think vaccination data out of New
Zealand he's facing jail time don't know
enough about it uh we'll have to read
more but uh there you go he's facing ja
jail time for releasing information
about Co I think it was vaccine uh data
that was like released to the public
something like that he's a good guy and
they're going to throw him in jail good
that's that's good to know well Rudy
cassone says Nikki Haley I'm guessing
she doesn't open her mouth must be
hiding her lizard tongue okay I'm sorry
guys it's disqualifying it's
disqualifying it it just is Nikki Haley
when she talks she doesn't open her
mouth she she does this weird for real
she does this weird thing where she
Bears her teeth and only moves her lips
and I'm actually really impressed cuz
it's not easy to do you talked you
talked about this on two segments today
right because I have to watch the videos
of her I'm like I'm watching I'm
watching uh the debates and Nikki Haley
is talking like this her lips are moving
but her teeth don't move at all and I'm
like what is she doing maybe oh I don't
want to I don't maybe why she doing her
top teeth are big so it doesn't look
like they're moving no dude they're not
moving sometimes they move for sure not
absolute but but she's gritting she
she's talking through her teeth like
when you're yelling at your dog what are
you doing she was mad at Viv a my guess
is it's a face lift is part of it so is
like is like this while while the mouth
goes yeah maybe or in a neck tension for
sure
like NE watch on the debates her lips
move a lot and her teeth stay there I'm
like that's that's crazy may maybe it's
not new maybe she's the lizard person
huh I didn't know that yeah you can't
I'm learning I'm learning a lot tonight
man I'm not a fan not a fan it is funny
how the have you noticed like all the
media reporting that Nikki Haley won the
debate really it's so weird yeah she won
the debate she couldn't name three
provinces in Ukraine that was brutal
from uh
V all right Ben D says Tim need to
correct you on things in 2021 as part of
the American Rescue plan student debt
forgiveness was legislated not to be
taxable income through 2025 Democrats
are smart evil and plan well I heard
well there you go yeah Joe Biden is uh
canceling another five billion they just
announced it's what yeah it's called
bribing bribing the American public
buying buying them voters y
yep Ian Slater says 17th lol I think you
were like fifth but you know right on
Deadpool says the music was amazing last
Friday would be awesome to get Serge
tanken to sing empty walls and IRL is
that the guy from uh system of it down
yeah yes we'd absolutely love to have
him on the show
System of a Down come
on all right Alpha turkey says Ben's
hatred for Vi is something to behold
you're talking about Ben Shapiro yeah I
think when you just say Ben everyone
knows who you're referring to he didn't
like VI why come you do like him he's
not like them ever he's a disis guy yeah
he's he's friends with him but he's not
a not a fan of him oh okay so he I see
what you say so he does like him but he
doesn't support him for president yeah
he's friends with
vake well all
right Logan Culver says VI is Millennial
Ron Paul changed my mind I swear if I
get sent one more video of the vi Obama
thing I'm just like dude I don't care
they're like did you notice that V said
things that Obama said and I'm like okay
I don't know he's studying politicians
and trying to learn how to be an
effective uh oror next qu what's the
point I liked how he turned to Chris
Christie and kind of like emasculated
him I was like just get off the stage
come on why are you go have a nice meal
yeah and it's like yeah that is how I
want my executive to talk to to down to
other leaders like you need to establish
y that that video going viral of Barbara
Walters being like you're too fat to be
president did you see that no I didn't
see it and he's like she's like I'm
sitting here across from you and I
notice you are overweight and he goes
very and she goes why and he's like if I
knew I'd fix it she goes well some
people say you're too fat to be
president and he was like that's that's
ridiculous that's I don't know if she
like that bluntly but you know I'll say
it right now I mean the dude's got major
health problems I mean look I any I
don't think that I think it's
responsible to put people that are that
are unhealthy like that in positions of
not just not just positions of power but
positions that we that we look up to I
was talking to uh to Brett about this
today on PCC or before PCC we need to
bring back aspirational no more of this
ads that mimic reality and television
shows that mimic reality and blah blah
blah I want aspirational things I want
Attractive people in my ads I want
attractive people that we are that that
us that make people aspire to be better
than they are and I think those are the
people that should should get uh should
get some of should get more Focus from
society I think we want to go to Mars
yeah I mean that's aspirational you know
but I think that I think National vision
and a national plan and something that
unites us so yeah the but the idea that
that we should focus on average every
day and mundane and that's what we
should put in our in front of our faces
all the time because that's what reality
is I think that we should we should
reject that and we should look towards
more aspirational things I like when
average mundane becomes awesome over the
course of a movie because then you're
like well now I know what average is
that's the hero's journey yes all right
Comey watermelon says cast brew coffee
and Shadow run it's a good night make
Shadow run great again what is that
shadow run is like uh postapoc it's like
no it's like a fascist corporate
corporatized Global governance D and D
like in the future I thought I thought I
I I thought that's what it was you
mentioned it before there's magic and
dwarves and all these like fantasy
characters but it's all we got we got to
do that yo like we need to do this okay
we need to do the culture War D and D
game it could be really good I mean that
would be an like I mean we we we we we
play it live we do it for like four hour
how many hours should a campaign go two
plus but more than two it's got to be
like a campaign probably should go
campaign 30 40 50 hours over course of
like so I'm saying like month sit down
for 2 three hours a day so I I think
there already exists like a political
version of D and but we need to
formulate it as to the modern politics
and do like so you you know what like
the Democrats and the neocons did in
2020 that is war game they basically
play Dungeons and Dragons but the
characters were like Hillary and Trump
and Biden and uh they War gamed out what
would happen by Rolling die and like
playing d and d and so I'm like we
should do a show that creates the
campaign throughout 2024 and like stays
a little bit ahead of what what's going
on yeah make half works great again well
we would we wouldn't call them half
works you you'd have like politicians
you know the point the point of the game
is like you're a lobbyist for rathon you
know what I mean have you guys ever
played a a video game on the show like
that we wouldn't do it on this show we'd
make a different show and do it we we we
we did film one time we played D and D
that was kind of fun but not it wasn't
like a live thing or anything like that
cool but uh maybe maybe gamer Maids yeah
I was thinking that today it could be
like a all inclusive gamer Channel like
it doesn't have to just be video games
the whole idea of like gamer men and
gamer Maids like let's roll with it
gamer men gamer men and gamer Maids yes
I'm a proud G no but for real like how
do we do this we need we need someone
who knows politics and DND and can craft
this maybe you should DM it no you'd be
a great story tell no no time for that
no time i't got no time for for that but
we it's like a Sunday night yeah we
could do it a a Sunday Night Live show
and then you're basically like okay the
prime AR is happening you like I'm going
to roll and see what happens like oh man
you know no Donald Trump actually lost
Iowa how did that happen oh that's
interesting yeah and then you'd have
like proud boys and antifa and whatever
it'd be
hilarious all right anyway all right
where we at Nick Napper says Tim man you
look tired uh I am the antithesis of
tired uh I feel great but thank you
thank you for your concern uh man I
barely sleep I can't sleep I sleep like
six hours a night meditate uh no I just
did that it was great no I took a sa
what about melatonin you take any
melatonin none of that you work out uh I
skate per a lot and so uh we've been
we've been skating a lot and filming a
lot does that help does that help you
sleep when you I no no no I don't have
trouble going to sleep I just don't need
that much sleep oh so I I go to bed
usually around like 1:00 a.m. then I
wake up around uh it's 6 and a half
hours I wake up around 6:30 I'm I'm
sorry 7:30 so yeah it's pretty awesome
sleep and rest are different things you
can can rest while you're awake and you
can get sleep and not get rest that's
for sure work throughout the morning uh
I've been working a lot faster I've been
trying to get things done sooner but it
only it only works depending on what
like the news is so right now we're in
like things are getting kind of dense
newswise so it allows me to record more
quickly and then I've been skating
around like 1 p.m. where I usually would
skate around 3 p.m. gives me a little
bit more time to go get food and then
come back and hang out and then we get
ready for the show around like 6:30
onward and then we finish at 11:00 and
then I'm in bed by 11:30 and then I just
watch I I I been usually I just watch TV
shows but uh recently we were at a bank
and one of the bank tellers had
Jiu-Jitsu kaisen as his his his desktop
background and so uh I was like I'm G to
watch that show and then I just spammed
it anime yeah so is that is that your
show your like genre of choice right now
is no I mean like when you when you have
uh so the boys great show geny I like
that and then uh what was the other
thing I was watching um I I I much
prefer shows like that but then recently
just because some guy at a bank was was
was watching it I was like I guess I'll
check it out and then actually I think
it's pretty good it's pretty good cool
but uh I don't know Juju kais means
sorcery battle sorcery battle Yeah
that's basically what it's about and
people uh like it you basically take any
anime like modern anime and they're all
like identical you know what I mean you
ever see that the thing where they they
took uh yeah energy blast or whatever
someone took the top four country songs
over like four years and then laid them
over each other and it's the same
song so that's that's how anime works
too it's like when it works you know it
works all
right Sakurai 13 says I stopped eating
bread after I realized it was staying
fresh a month after the expiration date
mhm I don't like to eat things like that
you put fresh in quotation
marks you I feel like that I feel like
that is more indicative of them tell
telling you that it goes bad long before
it's actually going to go bad so you buy
more than it is actually a problem with
the food yep so however I I think it's
also depending on the bread like
McDonald's doesn't rot or mold so there
so if you get Wonderbread just like
white Wonderbread like the plain old
white Wonderbread that stuff will be
moldy with like real fast and I feel
like that's because of the sugar content
in it that's what I was think but I
don't but if you get like all natural
bread that's stuff will last and last
and last no no no no Ian I used make
bread like every day and it would mold
in a couple days if you keep it dry it
stays better longer if you stay keep it
dry yeah in like five days after after
two days you're you're like there's any
moisture plastic bags make it go moldy
really quick but if it's in like a dry
thing with holes in it you can kind of
like a Bread Basket you can keep it five
days maybe seven top but usually by
seven You' got mold on it five probably
five Rob says Phil should use his failed
musician skills and see if Shawn
Danielson of Smile Empty soul and Aaron
Lewis of stained would come on the show
also I hear James Hetfield is pretty
based Ian you're the man dude rock on uh
I don't know uh the guys in smileing D
Soul or James hfield but I do know Aaron
I'm trying to get a hold of him but I
haven't been able to he actually just
left he was he was here uh a week ago
yeah last week trying to get in touch
with him to see if he can so he he he
played at Hollywood Charlestown and uh I
was like oh maybe maybe he'll have time
but it looked like his schedule wouldn't
have made sense so I don't know if our
people reached out to his people or
whatever happened but I think he was
coming straight from like Philly yeah so
it was like no no one's going to do a
show and then do a morning like no one's
going to play a live show up to midnight
then do a Morning Show and then do
another show that night be cool to have
him on the culture War though oh yeah
yeah yeah that'd be really great I I
really like that guy man who is Aaron
Lewis yeah yeah reading reading what he
wrote he wrote that song that was really
big about America you know right and
he's from he's from Springfield like's
he's from the town that I grew well the
town just south of where I grew up yeah
but seeing see uh reading about his
explanation for like why he wrote it and
why he decided it's it's it's amazing
he's a good dude oh yeah stained okay I
Guy music he's great oh yeah they got
tons of great stuff yeah it's been a
while is that stand oh man it's been a
while dud that song is hot I love that
song all right Andrew 8 843 says
disabled veteran here why can't the
major Richard star act get a vote in
Congress which one is that major Richard
star act I am not familiar uh I don't
know it off the top of my head i' have
to look it up Andrew just lobbied
Congress right now that Super Chat maybe
now you'll you'll look into it and maybe
something will happen who knows yeah
maybe it turns up to be a really bad act
then he's like whoa this guy's crazy or
maybe it's something really good that
needs to get some conversation we'll
figure it
out brown bear says as much as I want to
see Trump get his revenge after last
night I honestly think VI would be a
better president I
agree but uh the issue with VI
is you know all in all in due time I
think V would be an excellent president
I think first he'd be a great VP I know
he probably doesn't want to do that but
I wonder if that's just him saying
publicly I don't want to be VP because
he needs to maintain the composure of
I'm a leader I'm not just here to be VP
but I I don't know I think he I think
he' do a fantastic job actually me too
man and I I want to throw in on that one
here's the deal though a lot of
politicians are great at talking oh yeah
right and so as far as I'm concerned is
Vic vake great on a debate stage
absolutely but you know until you you
can't really judge any of these folks
until you see them under pressure and
that's the reason why I'm Trump all the
way because we've we've seen them throw
the kitchen sink at him and he he
doesn't stop like he doesn't change
course and he's willing to stand in the
Gap no matter what which is why you know
v may be strong you know if he got into
one of these pre pressure situations but
we already know Trump is and that's why
you know I'm I support Trump all the way
because politicians are great at talking
and talk is cheap and that that that's a
another good point I'd like to see V
take a on office he's got aate VP but uh
apparently the rumor is uh Melania wants
Tucker to be VP I I kind of I think
Tucker would be yeah I think Tucker
would be a better VP than VI VI's
leadership material V Should fig figure
it out I don't know I think he's
fantastic but Trump Carlson
2024 man that be that'd be the popul
awesome yeah but I agree on the Revenge
thing it doesn't thrill me as a message
to send to the the people I don't want I
don't want to no he's saying he does
want it oh he agrees that revenge is
cool I don't know but he says despite
that I do think the would be better yeah
having a a give being given a plan and a
blueprint of the future is is
exhilarating I like Revenge I like you
know and it's funny because you got
these pundits being like Donald Trump
doesn't care about you he only wants
revenge for himself and I'm like yeah
I'm I'm I'm on board with that yes okay
next next question are you kidding Trump
going in and firing a bunch of people
yeah great let him get his revenge all
have a good times when they did that
quote too where they they asked him if
he was going to be authoritarian the day
he went in or if he was going to abuse
his power yeah and he he answered the
question without listening to the
question he answered it in a way that
didn't make sense so I don't think he
said yes I'm going to abuse my power he
was just like he he going to do it on on
the first day close the border and
Deport a bunch of people close the
border and drill and drill drill drill
yeah that's it close the was like yes
but going after your opponents he's like
we're going to drill and he's like so
you're saying you want to bring things
back to the way they were okay next
question we're going to
drill want to close the
border Mikey says yo Tim it's my
birthday happy birthday is that Mickey
or Mikey I think it's
Mickey the ninjab bear says Tim you have
to have movies like Monty Python and die
hard playing in the studio Mary hasn't
seen them Phil and peeps Empire is the
best Star Wars movie Jedi is just
Muppets Ian web 3.0 blockchain we were
talking about Star Wars uh before the
show listening to the show today P PCC
today oh what they were talking about it
yeah because I mentioned uh in on
Twitter that you know basically we we
talked about how Luke Skywalker got
radicalized by religious zealots to go
blow up a military base there
canonically there's between one and two
million people innocent or two 1 to two
million total on the Death Star in later
books they said oh it's it's empire
propaganda was 800,000 and I'm like is
that better I mean dude come on Luke
Skywalker killed a million people and
it's canonical uh it is Canon that uh
many of the people who who were on the
Death Star had their families there
working as well and many of them were
civilian contractors because it has to
be I mean there's no reasonable
storytelling with well we evacuated all
civilians and the only people there were
evil military men people people's
families are there and so uh my a point
I eventually got to was I think you know
people people are saying yeah but the
Death Star BW alderon and I'm like n
that that's Rebel propaganda dude Al
blew itself up you guys sorry to tell
you yeah because they were they were
stockpiling weapons to use against the
innocent you know people they're
religious zealots and then when when it
blows up they just they blame it on the
Empire it's a false flag and but more
importantly real quick the story of
Anakin Skywalker in Revenge of the Sith
is the most unbelievable and implausible
scenario I've ever heard here's this guy
who's a military hero beloved by the
people who is working on behalf of the
government
legally and then one day just one day
for no reason he murders the head of the
Jedi Council and then decides an hour
later to Massacre children that sounds
like Rebel propaganda mental illness no
but like my point is it's just bad story
writing like Anakin Skywalker is like
you can't kill him he must stand trial
and mace Wu is like no he's too evil so
literally it's Anakin being like we must
uphold the law and then an hour later
he's like I guess I'll kill a bunch of
kids like that story arc makes no sense
whatsoever so I want to make a short
film we got to figure this one out where
it's basically inverting the propaganda
and making Star Wars from the
perspective of the Empire they wouldn't
call themselves The Empire that's silly
propaganda they'd call themselves The
United States of of of space we'll say
states of space yeah and then there's a
religious zealot grp group of religious
zealots that they they they blow up a
military base killing millions of of
people including hundred thou hundreds
of thousands of civilians if if the
death St blown up alderon would they
have been Justified and murder and would
it even be murder I asked you guys that
before the show if they for Luke blowing
that Death Star up with a million people
on it was it
Justified I say
no I say yes I think so it's it's it's
it's all in the storytelling and the
storytelling is the only way to do it
was this one weakness where they sent in
the bomb and then it blew the whole
thing up and then everyone said that was
stupid and so then they made the prequel
Rogue one where the guy building that
goes I've I've implanted a secret
weakness so that my daughter could blow
it up I'm like yeah okay great sheep
right because the reality is they would
stage an attack on and this is a this is
a moon-sized base they'd attack the
weapon they would disable the weapon and
not Massacre everybody on the on the on
the base and honestly try and take it
over if you I mean maybe that's
impossible yeah I want to answer that
guy he said Empire was the best of the
Star Wars and the Return of the Jedi was
a bunch of you're right it was but it
was the best in my opinion because the
way Luke turned Darth Vader to the light
side is like just what great
storytelling and that that happened in
Jedi yeah it was the end of Return of
the Jedi yeah not Empire no that's why I
think Jedi's better is cuz he did it in
Jedi I just like that story is like yo
yes you can redeem okay yeah I disagree
with that yeah it was it was it was so
stupid how they made him evil in the
first place that was just so dumb your
your your wife died from sadness and now
you murder children like why did Anakin
kill a bunch of kids like super cheap I
will do anything you say what why like
come on man give give me something to
believe the dude wants to be evil not
just the what have I
done yikes but anyway my point is we
could take those clips and then make a
short film where we're like this is all
Rebel propaganda that's not how Anakin
Anakin didn't murder a bunch of kids for
no reason it can start off with like an
old man reading this end of the story
and it turns out he's like a rebel
propagandist they're like oh yeah that
guy and then when you like find out it's
all Rebel propaganda I think you just do
the movie and you do it from perspective
the Empire and then there you go like it
just you don't have Darth Vader killing
people killing children for no reason
like that just makes no sense it doesn't
even fit his story arc no I mean for
real if they want to make him evil they
there was no point in making him go to a
temple to murder children it didn't do
anything for the story I was thinking
like Princess Bride other there's the
narrator he's like but if you really
want to know what happened and then he
gets out the real book and he's like and
we wouldn't we we wouldn't be able to
call actually we might be able to call
it Star Wars in the Empire because we're
making fun of it Luke Luke is just some
Zealot oh we were talking about this too
like Ian mentioned that his uh his his
he comes home and he finds his parents
are murdered yeah Fried by lasers or
something all right let's break this
down so uncle and Aunt actually let me
ask you so uh you served overseas yeah
you get orders that there are people who
have stolen classified military weapons
material
and are and and and have hidden that in
a
location like how would that play out if
you were ordered to go to that house you
and like there they're they're not
cooperating you have to like kick the
door in like you've got to get that
stuff back yeah so so the scenario would
be the Stormtroopers they call it oh
come on that's propaganda the servicemen
and women receive vital instruction that
weapons classified weapons materials
plans and uh means of exploiting blowing
up a military base have fallen into the
hands of religious zealot terrorists
they deploy to this planet All Desert
they go to this house last known
location of the Droid carrying the
information and what happens the people
there resist I mean so this is not this
is not this is not an easy situation and
I don't know what the answer is going to
be but the end result was they die the
military then collects what they can
they find nothing they leave Luke
Skywalker comes home to find his parents
are dead and then says the evil empire
killed my killed or Uncle sorry and he's
like they killed my aunt and uncle and
now I want revenge and that's probably a
true story for what happens with the
United States in the Middle East all the
time and if you think about the DraStic
nature that the the empire was under is
like if during the Manhattan Project if
our plans for the nuclear bomb got
leaked to the Nazis and it was in a
location and we had to send in Special
Forces to get it back like there is no
time to you don't ask if you can have it
like well let's let's put it this way
the plans for a for uh uh the schematics
for the World Trade Center
are stolen by terrorists with also the
capability and the means and the plans
to destroy them and everyone inside and
soldiers are ordered to go recover that
to put a stop to this plan and in in the
search these two people are killed they
resist they say oh get out of here a
fight breaks out the guys with guns wins
that's the key word the key word uh
there is resist right and it like in in
a situation like that it depends on what
level of resistance right if you feel
like you can handle you can handle the
situation without lethality that's
absolutely what you do but if if you
don't if you feel like you need to
escalate it to lethality then that's how
it works we got to make this short film
it's gold man right I definitely feel
like I should have beefed up on my Star
Wars before coming
out completely inadequate to even did
you see the first three I think yeah I
did I did but I'm definitely not at the
level of you guys man man they were so
good that's my bad Luke comes home and
his aunt and uncle or dad and then a
religious just sky and robes comes and
he's like let me explain to you the
truth about the evil empire and he's
like what's the evil empire well you
might call them the United planets you
know of the Milky Way but we call them
the evil empire and then he's like whoa
and the guy gives him a gun basically
like dude hands him a weapon right away
Luke was going to join how old was Luke
16 something young young and the dude's
like here's a laser weapon and he's like
wow it's like it's it's also funny with
Harry Potter they're basically giving
kids guns like you give a wand and and
then Harry Potter slashes a kid in the
back luk B were going to join the uh the
United Empire of planets oh yeah but
we'll talk more about that later uh Ram
Charger says I was a member of the US
Coast Guard which is part of the DHS I
was one of many who kick who was kicked
out over not being vaccinated if
Congress is willing to make the dod and
DHS take us back with back pay and back
promotions no matter our discharge stat
uh uh is Congress willing to make the do
DOD and DHS take us back with back pay
back promotions no matter their
discharge status no what do you think
about that yeah if it was for the vax
Mandate I absolutely would be I've
talked to a couple members on the uh the
VA committee about that same thing a
couple other veterans and uh I I do
think there's an appetite amongst it
from uh certain members of the
conference I don't know if if we could
get right now to pass something in
Congress you would need 218 votes and I
think we have like 221 people so it's a
it's a tall order to get any piece of
legislation through Congress and then
you have to get it through the Senate
and then Biden would have to sign it but
it goes back to what I was talking about
that that that's one way right there
that they could start to reestablish
some trust amongst not only folks that
have served but in you know amongst
younger Generations if they want to get
their recruiting numbers up let me try
Okay I'm going to try and get your name
right it's uh is it uh week zapach I
totally got it wrong but I was close
right I say that we vote to take Ian's
rocks away all in favor say I
unfortunately we are in a republic where
uh the Sheep is well armed and can
contest the
vote oh that's so everyone in chat can
we're not a democracy you can't um I
being the representative however if
elected will uh issue my decision on
voting to take away Ian's rocks what
rocks do they want Ian well he gu
probably want this aquamarine no doubt
it's beautiful and maybe this amethyst
which I love L I think think problem is
ladies and gentlemen as your
representative here at timcast I'm
actually the one who gave Ian a bunch of
those rocks true you'd have to go
through it be like a divorce settlement
I don't want to do these mushrooms are
great I got him in a triangle like the
Triforce everyone's voting to take away
yours so don't do it that's where I get
my power I'm just kidding by the way we
can do we could do a bit where Ian's
rocks get stolen and he just he's
wearing a suit reading the Bible Rockman
we do super that took the Rocks no he
should be polishing a chess board like
sha or doing the chess board like sha
Shank Redemption like can't out my head
yeah they they give him all the rocks
and he makes a chess board chess pieces
out of it that's good idea that's cool
Raymond g Stanley J says Tim likes chair
dancing to Taylor Swift you know the
last thing I want to bring up on this is
like if you saw my segment on this one
the there's a scup going on right now to
convince Trump supporters to attack
Taylor Swift you know why because Taylor
Swift publicly called out George Soros
she did and Alex Soros because they
bought her music her master recordings
out from under her and now for some
reason a bunch of trump supporters are
actually attacking Taylor Swift
insulting her and I'm like why are you
starting a fight with someone who
actually just opened the door for an
opportunity there right like you can go
to all Taylor Swift's fans right now and
be like hey Taylor Swift fan did you see
how George Soros screwed over Taylor
Swift yeah we also don't like George
Soros right instead people are like
Taylor's awful and she's a Democrat so
condemn her and I'm like why oh it's so
weird it's so weird that's cool man the
uni party is definitely where we should
be focused yeah just don't like first of
all if if Taylor Swift is going to vote
Democrat and push all these things and
she probably will why go to war with the
most popular celebrity it just makes no
sense because people are dumb so we got
to get Taylor over here all right James
hates everything says you've clearly
never seen troops Google Owen and Barrow
were were were a domestic dispute yes I
have but it's not what I'm talking about
I'm saying I want to make it totally
inverted right but anyway my friends
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net
co-opted so it's great to have alternate
you know places where people can come
and just listen to regular people talk
about you know I think uh uh you know
different perspectives right on and and
the good news I think Independent Media
is winning and it's been it's been
gradually just going up and up and up so
that's fantastic 100%
100% I am uh Phil that remains on Twix I
am Phil that remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
uh you can follow us on Spotify on Apple
music on Pandora uh YouTube you know the
internet yeah Eli I hope you come back
man that was awesome this is really good
and people going to follow you on
Twitter it's said Eli cranor CEO is your
personal account and then it's uh rep
Eli crane is your is your Congressional
account so yeah thank you I probably
should have said that man hey let me do
it for you I'm a hype man that's what I
do thank you brother always pleasure
dude yeah you too man and sege tell me
about it y uh yeah give me that
microphone juice that spot's fixed over
there so whenever we're
get over there yeah just the cable burnt
out it's working before what sound Che
like 6:00 so I just burnt out say love
you yeah cool all right everybody we
will see you all over at timcast.net